Aber das sind so die drei
prinzipiellen Szenarien, die ich da vorschlagen kann.
Da müsst ihr euch jetzt was aussoben,
weil es wäre natürlich blöd,
wo wir das jetzt aus dem Demo...
Ja, alle ist drei davon.
Wir haben es halt.
Wie heißt euer
Gast, der immer nach Schweden fährt?
Sascha.
Du hörst
unseren Podcast nicht.
Nee, wenn ich anfange, dann
viertel ich ja erst mit der
Abspielgeschwindigkeit, dass die mal richtig ist.
Oh, fuck.
Das lässt es mal verkacken.
Scheiße.
Hi Kian.
Was ein Intro.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 32.
In der Tat.
Da sitzt noch jemand am Tisch.
Oh mein Gott, wo kommt der her?
Herzlich willkommen bei Penta Radio, der monatlichen Radiosendung von Kauskons.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Fuck.
Vollkommen verlaufen.
Du hast da glaube ich was falsch verstanden.
Das ist jetzt mein neuer Running Gag, denn das war jetzt auch das Intro vom letzten Aufwachen Podcast, war auch, dass ich anfange Penta Radio anzumoderieren und dann kommt Moe und meint, nein, ein Halt, stopp, hier ist das Aufwachen Podcast.
Moment, Moment, Moment, also wir haben jetzt hier gerade irgendwie so eine Cameo von jemandem, der offenbar ständig in irgendwelchen Podcasts auftritt, nämlich bei uns hier in unserem kleinen Akronomisierbar-Studio sitzt mit am Tisch Stefan Majewski.
Hallo.
Oder auch Cyril.
Oder auch Cyrell. Herzlich willkommen bei Akronomisierbar.
Du warst ja schon mal bei uns hier zu Gast.
Du hast eigentlich eine ganze Akronomisierbar-Folge quasi mit alleine geschmissen.
Und zwar die als Vertretung für Kilian auf dem Kongress.
Ich kann überlegen, was ist das?
Genau. Vielleicht ist dir nicht aufgefallen, dass Kilian nicht dabei war, weil Julian da mit am Tisch saß.
Der hat auch rote Haare und einen Bart.
Kenne ich immer noch nicht.
Ja, und vielleicht können wir dich mal ganz kurz vorstellen.
Ich meine, du hast wahrscheinlich einen größeren Internet- und Podcasting-Footprint als wir, aber vielleicht...
Potenziell, ja, auch wenn ich zurzeit so quasi dieselbe Richtung einschlage wie alternativlos und immer seltener und seltener und seltener sende,
aber zumindest was meine eigenen Sendungen angeht.
Alternativlos sendet noch?
Ja, es gab letztens eine Folge tatsächlich vor einem halben Monat.
Also, du bist hier auch aus Dresden, Hacker und...
Also ursprünglich aus Schwerin und dann habe ich dann, als es dann daran ging zu studieren, festgestellt,
dass Schwerin über keinerlei Infrastruktur für höhere Bildung verfügt.
Wir hatten ja nichts.
Na, wir hatten ja nichts.
Und habe mich deswegen umgeguckt, wo man irgendwie sowas machen kann,
was noch einigermaßen vielleicht nicht so wie München oder Berlin oder so ist,
wo ich mich irgendwie dumm und dusselig bezahle.
Sehr verständlich.
Und habe dann Dresden gefunden, habe dann hier erstmal Physik studiert.
Dann habe ich dann festgestellt, dass das Problem war,
ich habe 2006 angefangen, Physik zu studieren.
Und da haben quasi alle gesagt, es gibt viel zu wenig Physiker, ihr müsst alle Physik studieren,
dann habt ihr super Jobaussichten.
Dann haben das alle gemacht und dann sind alle fertig mit dem Studieren und ja, scheiße.
Super.
Jetzt ist der Markt leider überschwemmt mit frischen Absolventen.
Und ich war dann auch in die Theorieschiene gegangen.
Und deswegen war dann so meine wesentliche Aussicht, irgendwie halt in der Forschung weiter zu bleiben.
Und das hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch gemacht, wenn ich dann ein konkretes Thema gehabt hätte in dem Moment.
Aber meine Diplomarbeit war halt leider fertig, ausentwickelt.
Konnte man jetzt nichts weiter groß dran machen.
Und da habe ich so gedacht,
vor ich jetzt hier irgendwie suche
so ein Thema, wo ich dann auf so einer halben Stelle
irgendwie bin für drei Jahre und dann muss ich wieder was
Neues suchen und so. Und das ist alles viel zu anstrengend.
Und dann hat man so als einzigen
Ausweg am Ende, dass man irgendwann Professor
wird und dann im Prinzip Politiker ist.
Also Freunde
lassen Freunde keinen akademischen
Karriereverteilen.
Aber ich kenne
eigentlich aus der Hacker-Szene viel mehr.
Wir sind uns ursprünglich
vor einigen Jahren im ASCII begegnet,
für rumhängig ist, ich weiß, damals
habe ich mir ja dein Gesicht gemerkt, weil du
gemeint hattest, dass du an KDE mitentwickelt
hast. Auch ja, das war passiert
so neben dem Physikstudium damals, da habe ich
dann, als gerade
so KDE 4.0 rauskam, also ich war auch
einer dieser Leute, die da
die allererste Technical Preview installiert haben,
die sie sich nicht getraut haben, Alpha zu nennen
und war da total
begeistert davon und so, das ist jetzt
hier die Zukunft, krass.
Und dann drei Jahre später war es dann auch stabil
und da habe ich dann angefangen...
4.3 oder sowas.
Und da habe ich dann so gedacht, hier
nutze ich jetzt nicht dieses Qt4 hier und baue
jetzt gleich was richtig Geiles, da habe ich dann angefangen so ein
Spiel zu bauen, weil jeder fängt ja an, erstmal Spiele zu
programmieren und habe das dann da
veröffentlicht, da auf kdeapps.org
also so quasi der, was
KDE so ein bisschen so versucht hat
als ein App Store aufzuziehen
und da kam dann irgendwann so ein Entwickler
halt von KDE Games an und meinte so
hey geil, das können wir einfach mal in unsere Software
Collection mit aufnehmen und ich so
oh, kann man das nicht so machen.
Geht das einfach so?
Ich hab doch gar keine
Ausbildung für sowas.
I'm not prepared. Und dann wurde
Car Diamond war das. Also es war ein Bejeweled-Klon.
Ach, Car Diamond ist von dir?
Ja, ja.
Das Artwork tatsächlich
nicht. Das hat dann da jemand
von dem Team da gemacht. Also wir haben halt da
einen Artist quasi gehabt, der da
für alle möglichen Spiele irgendwie Grafiken gemalt hat.
Und wir hatten da
haben wir so in Inkscape ganz schnell was zusammengeschmissen,
damit wir überhaupt irgendwelche Grafiken haben, die so mehr
Platzhalter waren. Und
ja, das kam dann damit rein und
dann steckte ich halt dann drinnen.
Ich dachte auch, wie du hattest an diesem Puzzlespiel
Das war dann das nächste danach. Das war dann
Palapiti. Das kann man sehr gut daran
sehen, wie die Benennung ist, weil man
hat immer so Phasen, wie man seine Software
benennt und das war die Phase, in der ich meine Software
benannt habe, indem ich einfach das eingegeben
habe in Wikipedia,
was es macht und dann die Übersetzung durchgeschaut
habe, bis ich irgendwas Lustiges gefunden habe. Das hat
meistens irgendwas skandinavischen geführt.
Wiki-Translate. Und Talapeli ist
Finish für Puzzlespiel. Cool.
Und das hab ich dann auch gemacht.
Das ist halt einfach so ein Puzzlespiel, wird halt ein Bild
reinschmeißt und
dann zerscheinst du es halt und dann
kannst du es wieder versuchen zusammenzusetzen und
ja, das war cool. Und
ja, in den anderen KDE-Games habe ich auch so ein bisschen rumgebaut.
Ich hab so eine generische Rendering-Komponente
gebaut, also die so mit
Thread, Worker, Pool und
allen SVG-Grafiken in die PNGs
umsetzt, die man dann zum Anzeigen braucht.
in die PixMaps,
die man anzeigen will.
Es ist schon nicht trivial,
so eine Grafik in Puzzleteile zu verschneiden.
Na, einmal das, ja.
Das habe ich tatsächlich auch geoutsourced.
Da habe ich nur so ein Interface
für Libraries gemacht und habe erstmal nur so
ganz einfache Library gemacht, die so Rechtecke ausschneidet.
Und dann kam dann irgendwann
Johannes Lötzsch an.
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht
durcheinanderwerfe, das war auf jeden Fall in Dresden,
das haben wir dann irgendwann so nach so einem Monat
Korrespondenz festgestellt, dass wir beide aus Dresden kommen.
und der hat dann halt
eine total krasse
Slicer Plugin geschrieben, was
halt alle möglichen krassen
Algorithmen und sowas eingebaut hat, also auch wo man dann
nach wo Neuregionen auch slicen kann und sowas
und
Ich glaube, das ist eine Podcast-Folge für sich
Das auf jeden Fall, da müssten wir glaube ich dann
den Autor dafür haben
denn ich habe da nur gesagt, krass geil
nehme ich, danke, weil das ist ja
die Power of Wii Software
und
Naja, so habe ich da so ein bisschen
rumentwickelt. Ich habe auch irgendwann
mir Kolf vorgenommen.
Das ist das bescheuertste Name für ein Spiel.
Ja, ja, das KDE Minigolf. Das ist aus dieser
Phase, als KDE so
kompulsiv alles mit K benennen musste.
Ist die Phase vorbei? Die Phase ist
vorbei. Echt? Schade.
Akonadi, Okular, Dolphin.
Aber Okular ist ja noch das K zumindest vorne mit drin.
Das mag sein, ja.
Bei Akonadi ist auch ein K mit drin.
Was? Akonadi hat auch ein K.
Akronomisierbar auch.
Wir sind eigentlich ein KDE-Podcast.
Spottet bei KDE, genau.
Das wäre mir neu, aber da kommen wir ja nachher in den Stars nochmal drauf.
Und ja, bei
Golf gab es,
da habe ich mich dann irgendwann so auseinandergesetzt,
weil da dachte ich so, das muss man jetzt nochmal fixen.
Da gab es so einen Bug, der war, glaube ich, als ich ihn am Ende
geschlossen habe, 8,5 Jahre alt. Und das ist ja auch
so ein Batch, den man sich so an
die Wand hängt oder ans Rewehr heftet
oder so, wie alte
Bugs man irgendwie schließen kann. Ich habe auch, glaube ich,
auf Arbeit irgendwann mal Code gelöscht, der von 99 war.
Man müsste von GitHub irgendwie für alte
Issues, die man zumacht, so eine Art
Plakette kriegen, die man sich an die Wand
hängen kann. Das wäre tatsächlich cool.
Das ist so eine Aufsummierung auf meinem Profil.
Von all die Issues ich geschlossen habe.
In langer, mühevoller
Arbeit, Issue
277 aus dem Jahr
2004.
Cool.
Da war der Bug. Golf ist halt
so ein 2D-Mini-Golf.
Es läuft da wirklich auf einer...
von oben.
Von oben guckst du halt rauf auf das
Puzzle, Quatsch, auf den Golfkurs
und kannst halt den Ball dann halt
langschlagen und es gab halt so einen langstehenden
Bug, dass der Ball manchmal durch Wände durchlischt.
Okay.
Wie ist es bei Physik-Engines so passiert, wenn man die
Abtastrate nicht richtig hinfällt?
Ja, also dann habe ich halt mal reingeguckt,
was halt eigentlich das Problem ist und dann habe ich halt
erstmal habe ich einen Schreck bekommen
und dann habe ich erstmal angefangen,
diesen Code so zu refaktorieren,
so Keyhole refaktorieren, also
nur irgendwelche Phrasen umbauen in lesbarere Phrasen.
Also zum Beispiel, dass ein Point zu einem anderen Point addiert wird,
in dem halt wirklich komponentenweise addiert wird,
anstatt dass A plus B hingeschrieben wird,
was da durchaus geht in C plus plus mit Operatorüberladung.
Und habe dann erst mal so irgendwie schon mal mehrere hundert Zeilen Code rausgenommen
und dann konnte ich irgendwann anfangen, den Code tatsächlich zu lesen,
anstatt nur so auf einzelne Zeilen zu gucken.
Und dann habe ich dann irgendwann die spektakuläre Funktion
Ball-to-Wall-Collision gefunden.
Die war dreieinhalbtausend Zeilen lang.
Das war quasi ein Physik-Engine.
Ja, das war halt ein Physik-Engine,
halt organisch gewachsen.
Also da hat jemand so gedacht, das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Hat einfach so 100 Zeilen hingeklatscht.
Achso, diese eine Corner-Käste,
den haben wir noch nicht. Hat nochmal 50 Zeilen.
Ach, da ist ja auch noch was.
Das ist, glaube ich, so das, woran sehr viel
Open-Source und gerade KDE-Code, glaube ich,
krank. Das ist C++-Code.
In C++ kann man sehr schnell einfach das Code bauen,
der abstürzt.
Und wenn der Code von dieser Qualität
so überall verstreut ist, dann kann ich mir schon erklären,
warum das ab und zu immer mal neue Bugs hat.
Ja gut, also ich meine, REST ist sicherlich kein Rust.
Aber das Thema haben wir ja, glaube ich,
in dem Podcast hier schon oft gehabt.
Ach Quatsch, wir reden über Sprachen, was?
Da habe ich dann einfach diese 3500-Zeilen-Funktion
und einige Sachen drumherum halt komplett rausgerissen
und stattdessen so eine Physik-Engine eingebaut,
also so Box 2D nennt sich das,
also einfach so eine ganz Standard-Kollisions-Engine.
Da hat sich dann aber als Problem herausgestellt, dass das Spiel halt nicht wirklich 2D ist,
weil es gibt so Plattformen, die sich so irgendwo auf festen Faden angewegen,
die so ein bisschen Floating sind.
Also sobald der Ball da raufkommt, bewegt er sich halt mit der Plattform mit
und dadurch ist es nicht mehr ganz 2D.
Also das ist am Ende nicht so ganz, dass diese Box so die alles macht,
sondern das macht im Wesentlichen halt die Wand-zu-Ball-Kollision.
Und danach kommt dann halt die Translation mittels der Erkennung dessen,
auf welcher von diesen Floating-Ding
das ist. Ja, super spaßig.
Es hat am Ende erstaunlich gut funktioniert.
Es hat leider all die Level gebrochen, die
darauf basieren, dass man durch die
Wände durchblitchen kann, wenn man passend spielt.
Das habe ich hingenommen,
um diesen Bug jetzt endlich zumachen zu können.
Ja, aber das wäre ja auch Quatsch.
Ich glaube,
der Bug hat da hingehört.
Ja, das ist ein Bugger.
Das hat sich über die Zeit zu einem Feature geworden.
Kennt ihr
diesen Monkey-User-Comic?
Große Augen.
Also geht mal auf,
lieber Hörer auch, geht mal auf
monkeyuser.com und zwar ist das einfach so
ein
Entwickler-Comics, ähnlich wie
ähnlich wie, wie heißt das andere?
Comet-Strip, bloß ein bisschen
Rohr und ist eigentlich auch
ziemlich cool. Davon poste ich eigentlich
regelmäßig Panels bei uns im firmeninternen
Slack, weil es genau auf uns zutrifft.
Und da
gibt es immer den Entwickler-
sieht aus wie so ein Ex-KCD-Männchen
mit einem blauen Hemd und den
QAler, das ist dann ein Redshirt.
Und dann gibt es so kleine grüne Männchen,
das sind die Bugs. Und die Bugs sind
immer Protagonisten in der eigentlichen,
in diesen Panelsystemen.
Das ist ziemlich witzig.
Kannst du dir mal vielleicht exemplarisch ein oder zwei
in Choros mitpacken.
Aber cool, du hast also
KDE-Code mitentwickelt und Spiele für KDE
gebaut und refactored.
Da ich gerade dieser Geschichte dran muss, ich habe noch eine Anekdote zu Ende erzählen.
Das war nämlich die Zeit, als KDE noch auf SVN war.
als ich reingekommen war,
damals 2008, also als der KDE4-Cycle
gerade voll am Laufen war, also so dieser
Ramp-Up zu KDE4.0,
war gerade die Migration von CVS
nach SVN abgeschlossen worden.
Git war aber auch noch brandneu.
Ich erinnere mich auch irgendwann, dass das irgendwann so 2010
oder so übelst gefeiert wurde, als der millionste
Commit im Subversion war.
Also schon ein Projekt von epischen Ausmaßen,
aber natürlich hat halt all die Probleme die SVN halt
hat. Das war auch nur ein großes SVN, ne?
Ja, ja, ein großes SVN
für alles.
Und das war dann auch gar nicht so einfach, das war mir so ein zwei Jahre langes Projekt auf Git umzuziehen, weil die haben eigenes Tooling dafür geschrieben, um das alles in einzelne Repos zu zerzerren, weil du ja quasi verfolgen musst, so ab Commit 987.000 lag dieser Tri jetzt unter fußlash bar slash colf und davor lag es halt unter fußlash quuff slash colf.
Was die Ordnerstrukturen zwischendurch natürlich auch ändern.
Ja, solche Sachen halt.
Oder halt zum Beispiel, wenn da aus einer Applikation eine Library rausgezogen ist,
passiert da sowas auch.
Und genau, das war halt SVN.
Und ich hatte halt damals schon festgelegt, dass SVN irgendwie Kretze ist,
so direkt zu verwenden, insbesondere wenn man so einen langen, offenen Branch hat,
wie ich da halt hatte mit diesem Rewrite, und hab dann halt GitSVN verwendet.
Ja, das war das dafür.
GitSVN war damals noch relativ neu.
Und, also naja, es gab es auch schon ein, zwei Jahre.
Wie viele Repos hast du damit kaputt gemacht?
Ja genau, das ist halt jetzt die Geschichte.
Ich hatte halt meinen Feature-Branch fertig.
Der hatte so 50 Commits
und hatte so etwa 10.000 Zeilen Änderungen drin.
Und das auch wirklich so,
nicht nur, wie ich habe jetzt hier Box 2D importiert,
sondern halt wirklich Änderungen,
wo ich Dinge angefasst habe.
Also das war schon so etwa 200 Monate Arbeit gewesen.
Und dann war ich halt so an dem Punkt,
so jetzt wird es halt gepusht.
Jetzt geht es halt wirklich in Master rein.
Also das ist ein S4N halt in den Trunk, in den Bussel.
Ja, in den Baumstamm.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe halt dieses S4N-D-Commit gemacht.
Wie jetzt im Auto, da, wo man
Kofferraum ist.
Mach also dieses
Git-SVN-Dekomit, was dann ja die
Commits nach SVN hochlädt und
er fängt so an und bei
Commit 20 kommt ein Fehler.
Und
zwar der Fehler war, dass ich halt Box 2D importiert
hatte und das hatte einfach Windows-Line-Endings
und da hat irgendein Commit-Druck vom
SVN hat das abgelehnt.
Ich meine, so mach mal doch bitte diese Line-Endings
weg. Und das Problem war aber, Git-SVN war halt
schon, wie gesagt, zwei Jahre alt, aber der
Der Corner Case war halt noch nicht aufgetreten wohl bei den Entwicklern.
Die haben halt so ein Handling dafür drin, wenn der erste Commit fehlschlägt,
weil du zum Beispiel keine Authentifizierung oder sowas hast.
Aber dass irgendwie zwischendurch so der 20. Commit fehlschlägt von 50,
das hatten sie nicht beachtet.
Und dann war halt wirklich alles zerschrotet.
Denn GIT SVN funktioniert ja auch so,
dass es dein Working Directory auf den Commit zurücksetzt,
damit es dann committen kann,
damit es das dann SVN hochladen kann und solche Späße.
Und es hatte wirklich alles geschrotet.
Und mir war damals auch das Revlog noch nicht bewusst oder es war nicht an.
und ich habe dann tatsächlich
über die blanke Git-Objekt-Datenbank
eine Suche gemacht nach Dingen, wie Commits aussehen,
habe erstmal überall Branches angelegt, damit nichts
gearbeitet wird und habe das dann
in kleinster Arbeit auseinandergepriemelt, was
jetzt passiert war und ich habe dann alles recovern können
am Ende, also Git ist toll.
Und es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall zu wissen,
wie diese Objekt-Datenbank funktioniert in Git.
Das
kommt ja eigentlich nichts weg.
Und wenn du den hintersten, den letzten
Commit gefunden hast, dann kannst du die gesamte
Kette damit wieder herstellen.
Es wird halt Garbage Collected, aber ja auch erst
nach N Tagen oder so.
Da gab es,
selbst dann verlierst du eigentlich nicht sehr viel.
Es gibt
eine Buchempfehlung, das fällt mir
gerade nicht genau ein, aber ich werde es mal in die Show Notes mit reintun.
Und zwar
es hieß glaube ich
Learning Git by Implementing It oder sowas.
Und da ist einfach eine Beschreibung, wie einer
Git in Ruby schreibt.
Das gibt zu kaufen.
Ich habe bloß den Typen
in irgendeinem Podcast interviewt gehört.
Das fand ich ziemlich spannend.
Es ist auch total witzig, sich mal so in dem Git-Repo,
also das Repo, wo Git drin liegt,
mal sich die allerersten Commits anzugucken,
wie Linus gerade sich da irgendwie anhand von einer Büroklammer
und zwei Gummiringen irgendwie selber bootstrappt.
Weil Git wurde ja von Anfang an in Git entwickelt.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, ja.
Das ist quasi die ersten Commits.
Das sind quasi mit den ersten Prototypen von Git.
Cool.
Also wirklich, ich finde es großartig.
Ich hätte gedacht, gerade mit den ersten Kommits ist noch irgendwie kein wirkliches Tracking da gewesen.
Aber ich finde es cool, dass sie da die Idee gebootstabt haben.
Er wird wahrscheinlich einfach noch keinen Ref-Log gehabt haben.
Also ich denke mal, was da nicht drin steckt, ist, dass Linus irgendwie erst mal vorher irgendwie eine Woche auf dem Blatt Papier rumüberlegt hat.
Und dann halt das Design festgelegt hat.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Linus Torwart sowas macht.
Der fängt einfach direkt an, euch ein C-Code zu schreiben.
Dann beleidigt er ein paar Leute, dann zeigt er Nvidia einen Finger und dann geht's weiter.
Aber gut, cool. Das war eine ziemlich coole Geschichte.
Die erste Commit-Nachricht ist Fuck NVIDIA.
Aber du machst natürlich noch andere faszinierende Sachen.
Du bist nämlich hier in Dresden im Chaos Computer Club mitorganisiert
und machst da den Dresdner lokalen Chaos Computer Club Podcast
slash Radiosendung.
Beide.
Naja.
Also mit dem Chaos Computer Club oder mit Makerspaces
ist es ja sowieso so, da gibt es ja keinen formalen Aufnahmeprozess.
Du gehst dann einfach hin und dann bist du jetzt da.
Also ich bin halt Anfang 2016
dann einfach mal hingegangen.
So, der Stefan ist jetzt auch da? Genau.
Anfang 2016 erst sogar? Ja, ja, so Größenordnung.
Und
ja, und dann bist du halt ab und zu da
und dann irgendwann nickst du an deinem Platz
ein, warst auf und hast du eine Inventarnummer auf der Stirn.
Und bist Vorstandsvorsitzender
passiert das.
Scheiße. Das war ja dann auch ein bisschen später,
aber ja.
Ja, und wir sind ja, wir haben ja
einen Verein, der das Ganze irgendwie trägt, weil irgendwer
muss irgendwie den Mietvertrag unterschreiben und irgendwie die
Nebenkosten bezahlen und solche Dinge.
Und das ist der Netzbiotop Dresden e.V.
Und das Vereinsgesetz,
das ist ja so auf Kaninchenzüchterverein
optimiert und so, das verlangt ja, dass man
einmal im Jahr eine Mitgliederversammlung macht.
Und dann muss der Vorstand Rechenschaft
ablegen, was so alles passiert ist.
Dann wird der Vorstand entlastet oder nicht.
Mir ist bisher auch nicht klar, was das jetzt genau heißt,
aus rechtlichen Gründen. Und das ist jetzt auch
egal. Und dann wird ein neuer
Vorstand gewählt. Das ist mir nach vier Jahren
Vorstandsvorsitzenden im Studentencafé Aski
auch immer noch nicht klar gewesen, was das bedeutet.
und es war dann halt einfach
Ende 2018 bei unserer letzten
Medienversammlung so, dass halt von den drei
Vorständen nur einer zur Wiederwahl angetreten ist
und dann geht so, dass
Gegenseitige mit dem Finger
auf andere Leute zeigen zu, denn man muss vorgeschlagen
werden von irgendjemandem und dann geht es halt reihe um, dass
jeder mal jeden vorschlägt und dann
kommt es halt darauf an, wer halt dann
nicht sagt, auf gar keinen Fall und es ist
also so, wie wenn man sagt, Freiwillige vor und
alle bis auf einen treten einen Schritt zurück.
Ne, wir hatten tatsächlich am Ende sieben
Kandidaten. Völlig überraschenderweise.
Aber die Leute haben mir dann
überwältigendes Vertrauen ausgesprochen,
was wahrscheinlich damit zusammenhängt, dass ich
mir einen geordneten Eindruck erwecke.
Du bist oft genug da.
Die Leute denken, nur weil ich
so ein Gnukash-File habe, wo ich meine
Barausgaben-Tracker heiße, dass ich
organisiert bin.
Der ist Gnukash, der weiß damit umzugehen.
Das ist allerdings ein guter Skill, weil Gnukash
wird auch für die Vereinsbuchhaltung verwendet.
Ihr habt mitbekommen, wie in den letzten
Tagen in manchen
ostdeutschen kleinen Ortschaften
Bürgermeister gewählt werden?
Oder was war diese Geschichte?
Die Lusten Knugherrstadt?
Nee, aber die haben irgendwie
CDU und SPD
haben zusammen einen NPDler
in irgendeine Stadtratsrolle gewählt,
weil er jung ist und E-Mails schreiben kann
und sich mit Computern auskennt.
Oh, der hat Ahnung.
Das hat der Postilion natürlich auch schon
durch den Kakao gezogen.
Das Gruselige ist, dass es nicht aus dem Postilion kam.
Extra 3 hat das
vertwittert und hinten dran geschrieben,
keine Pointe.
Naja, Pfeffer hat das auch aus der
Kategorie nicht der Postillon.
Aber cool, das heißt, du bist
im
Vorstand vom Netzbiotop
in Dresden zur Zeit.
Aber eigentlich den spannenderen Teil fand ich,
dass du selber auch
podcastest. Ja, ich mache was mit Medien.
Wir haben da beim
C3D2 dieses Penta-Radio.
Das läuft einmal im Monat und irgendwie auch schon
seit 10, 12 Jahren. Also beim
gehören wir auch mit zum Inventar. Da gibt es dann immer manchmal so, beim
Colorado gibt es dann immer Tageskoordinatoren, wo dann halt einer für den
Sendebetrieb verantwortlich ist und halt die aufgezeichneten Sendungen halt
ausspielt und so weiter. Und die haben halt ihren Plan, wo dann halt drin
steht, so vierter Dienstag im Monat 21:30 Uhr ist der Chaos Computer Club dran.
Und wenn das dann neue Leute sind, die das zum ersten Mal machen oder zum
ersten Mal unseren Slot haben, dann sind die erst mal verwirrt, weil irgendwie da
da steht keine Telefonnummer dabei, da wissen sie nicht,
wen sie kontaktieren müssen und das müssen wir ihnen erst erklären,
dass sie einfach wirklich mal eine Etage runtergehen müssen
und da ist der Hackers Face.
Wer will jetzt von euch, die hier gerade rumsitzt und gerade mal Radio machen?
Stimmt, beim Colorado saßen wir ja auch schon damit drin,
haben wir auch schon gemacht, im Datenschwund.
Genau, bei den Datenschwund, da gibt es sogar ein Foto von, wie wir da sitzen.
Ja, das passiert schon durchaus manchmal,
dass dann irgendwie so der TK, der sich damit auskennt,
dann mal so runterkommt, ihr wisst, dass ihr nachher Radio macht,
ja, ja, wir kommen dann hoch.
Schön.
Ihr habt ja jetzt den unwahrscheinlichen Vorteil,
dass ihr im gleichen Haus sitzt.
Vorher müsstet ihr ja woanders hinfahren.
Jetzt sitzt der...
Ich habe das auch nicht miterlebt damals.
Ich habe es halt miterlebt,
als ich dann halt gerade neu war im Space,
dass dann immer so ab und zu mal passiert ist,
dass dann so eine Gruppe sich gebildet hat,
die dann zusammen zum Koloradio gefahren ist.
Wo war das Koloradio vorher, bevor es im Internet war?
Das ist in der Neustadt bei der Groove Station um der Ecke.
Ah, okay.
Da war ich vor Jahren einmal,
als mit Blitz und MROI über Microcurl geredet wurden.
durfte ich auch an den Pulten sitzen.
Da bin ich ganz kurz mit
was läuft zu hören.
Als die Pause zu Ende war.
Aber ich finde,
du machst das eigentlich ziemlich professionell.
Du hast ja auch noch einen zweiten Podcast.
Zwei weitere.
Zwei weitere mittlerweile.
Ich bin gar nicht mehr im Bilde.
Ich bin ja noch chronologisch jetzt.
Okay, dann bleib mal chronologisch.
Ich merke, ich bringe deine Ordnung.
Meine Vorlesung bringst du dir völlig durcheinander.
Alle Tätelungen haben gebrochen.
Okay, wo waren wir?
Dort waren wir.
Bitte, bitte, fahren Sie fort.
Ich habe dann halt
im Juni
letzten Jahres, habe ich mal so gedacht,
jetzt machen wir doch mal eine Penta-Radio-Sendung
zu Cloud Computing, weil das ist das, was ich auf Arbeit
mache, darüber kann ich vielleicht was erzählen.
Und habe das dann halt so vorgeschlagen
und dann kam halt auch der A8
dazu, dessen Richtigname ich jetzt nicht kenne,
der will ihn doch, glaube ich, nicht hören im Radio.
Das ist der richtige Name.
Ja, genau. Und der
macht auch in der Errichtung was
und konnte dann halt auch so ein bisschen was
dazugeben und dann habe ich halt da so ein bisschen was
vorbereitet und war halt erst mal,
mir wurde halt so gesagt, ja, wir machen hier so
30 Minuten News und 60 Minuten Thema
und dann hast du halt 60 Minuten, wo wir dich ausfragen können
dazu und ich so, ach du Scheiße, wie soll ich denn
die Folge kriegen?
Siehst, ich war neu in diesem Podcasting-Feld
und
dann machen wir halt so diese Sendung und ich
habe halt vorher diese News-Liste gesehen gehabt, das waren so
fünf Stichpunkte mit Links dazu
und dachte so, okay, das kann doch nicht mehr als 10 Minuten dauern
Und dann haben wir diese News durchgesprochen, machen so die Musik, damit wir kurz mal lüften können.
Und ich gucke so, oh, jetzt sind 45 Minuten vorbei.
Das ist interessant.
Das läuft ja.
Man kommt halt so ins Reden.
Das kennen wir ja hier alle.
Dann muss ich zusammenreißen.
Wir haben auch die Stunde jetzt bereits zur Hälfte voll.
Was?
Ich dachte gerade, du sagst, die Stunde ist schon voll.
Ach du Scheiße.
Nee, wir sind bei einer halben Stunde.
Das hätte mich jetzt immer sehr überrascht.
Nee, das wird heute einfach eine besonders lange Folge, damit Sascha was zu hören hat.
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, es gibt Podcasts, die sich künstlich kurz halten und sagen,
so, wir haben eine Stunde, wir hören jetzt auf und ich so als
Hörer, der ich so eine Folge einfach
im Zweifelsfall dann später
weiterhöre oder immer mal ein Stückchen weiterhöre,
ich denke mir dann jedes Mal,
das ist aber schade drum. Aber es gibt solche
und solche Podcasts, auch Podcasts, die gerne mal länger
sind, das hört man auch mal, also
4-Stunden-Podcast, da muss ich sagen, da reicht meine
Motivation selten, den anzufangen, weil ja noch andere Dinge
auf der Queue liegen. Ich sep dann
so hin und her, dann höre ich halt mal ein Stückchen.
Wenn es gute Chapter-Marks gibt, das ist noch umso besser, weil dann kann ich
sehen, was ich höre. Das muss ich
nicht mal, weil ich höre mir dann einfach nur in einen anderen Podcast,
an und dann wandert der, den ich quasi
gerade unterbreche, als nächstes wieder?
Dann ist deine Q nicht voll genug. Bei mir gibt es immer 20 weitere
Sachen, die da noch sind. Ja, man muss ja nicht
alles abhören. Immer vier Monate, aber zu 90%
schon. Ich kriege nur die Sachen, die ich weiß,
die ich nicht hören möchte. Ich abonniere halt nur
die Sachen, die ich auch tatsächlich durchhören kann.
Und da ich halt den Aufwachen-Podcast höre, der zweimal die Woche
so vier, fünf Stunden hat, schaffe ich halt
kaum was anderes.
Auf anderthalbfache Geschwindigkeit geht es ja schon einigermaßen.
Ich komme nicht mehr hinterher. Seitdem ich umgezogen bin und
nicht mehr eine halbe Stunde lang jeden Tag, also eine Stunde
hin und her durch die Stadt fahre, habe
in meiner Queue einherzuwerden.
Ich habe 60 Podcasts, die da ständig reinpushen.
Man hört auf dreifacher Geschwindigkeit,
man kommt einfach nicht hinterher.
Du hast also Penta-Radio und Penta-Cast.
Sollte man nicht verwechseln?
Das ist nicht ganz das Gleiche.
Also Penta-Radio ist halt das, was einmal im Monat läuft
und wo dann halt die Podcast-Version
einfach die Aufzeichnung ist von dem, was da im Radio passiert.
Penta-Cast ist einmal alle drei Jahre läuft.
Penta-Cast ist halt, wenn irgendwas anderes passiert.
Da gab es jetzt zwei Jahre lang.
Das sind die außerordentlichen Folgen quasi.
Aber ich habe jetzt letzten Monat tatsächlich mal wieder eine Folge gemacht,
Pentacast 55 zur Landtagswahl.
War gut.
Gute Wahlhelfer-Stories.
Genau, habe erzählt, was ich so alles als Wahlhelfer erlebt habe,
denn das musste auch einfach mal raus.
Muss ich gleich mal wieder abonnieren.
Das ist halt auch so eine Sache, wenn ich das...
Entschuldigung.
Wenn ich das als...
Das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Ich sollte gleich mal mein Telefon stumm schalten.
Was war eure Klingel-Tel?
Dann wäre das ein epochaler Blogpost.
Dann hätte ich auch 20 Jahre daran gearbeitet,
bis das mal fertig wäre.
Und bei so einem Podcast, da kann man sich auch mal hinsetzen, einfach mal quatschen.
Und dann räumt man das noch so ein bisschen auf und poliert das und macht Phonik drüber und dann geht es ab ins Internet.
Phonik FTV.
Und die fand ich eine sehr informative Folge, auch generell.
Ich würde doch das nächste Mal gerne Wahlhelfer und dann mit sein, dank der Folge auch mit.
Wir hatten es ja mal erwähnt eigentlich sogar, dass du, also bei unseren beiden Folgen,
wo wir einmal über die Europa und einmal über die Landtagswahl geredet haben, dass du wieder Wahlhelfer bist.
Und dass du mich quasi daran erinnert hast,
dass ich es eigentlich machen wollte,
schon seit der letzten Landtagswahl
und ich es dann vergessen habe.
Ich glaube, du kannst dir auf der Webseite von dresden.de
kannst du dir irgendwo den Wahlhelfer-Newsletter abonnieren
und dann wirst du halt hinreichend früh benachrichtigt.
Also ich hatte da die erste Mitteilung
Anfang Februar bekommen.
Wahlhelfer-Newsletter.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das wirklich auch abonnieren kann,
wenn man noch nicht Wahlhelfer war
oder ob man dann einfach auf der Liste ist,
wenn man mal Wahlhelfer war.
Aber es kam so im Februar,
kam quasi die Information,
ja, dieses Jahr stehen drei Wahlen an.
sie können sich ab jetzt registrieren und dann habe ich es dann halt gemacht.
Und ja, und dann
kommt dann halt irgendwann, wenn dann halt die Wahlbenachrichtung
kommt, halt auch dieses, kurz darauf,
dieses Schreiben, ihre Berufung als
stellvertretender Wahlvorsitzender
in den Wahlkreis sowieso, bitte erscheinen Sie
hier zur Schulung. Wird da einigermaßen
drauf geachtet, aus welcher Ecke du selbst kommst
oder kann es sein, dass du irgendwie 10 Kilometer
durch die Stadt fährst? Du kommst nicht in deinen eigenen Wahlkreis.
Ich war einmal in der Unwahl, da war ich
im selben Gebäude, also in derselben Grundschule,
wo auch mein Wahlbezirk ist, aber halt ein Raum
weiter. Achso, damit du nicht deine eigene Stimme
einwirfst zumindest.
Genau, dass man halt zumindest
einen Raum weitergeht. Also jetzt
die beiden Male habe ich gebrief gewählt, weil
ich einfach die Befürchtung habe, ich bin so
fokussiert darauf, rechtzeitig zur Briefwahl Auszählung
da zu sein, dass ich vergesse, selber wählen zu gehen.
Die Briefwahl für die Auszählung.
So kann ich das Band auslappen.
Ja, Briefwahl, Quatsch, Quatsch,
Unwahl wäre nichts für mich, weil ich war
wie gesagt einmal da und da muss man halt einfach 6.30 Uhr
auf der Matte stehen als Vorsitzender
beziehungsweise 7 Uhr als Beisitzer
nein. Achso, du meinst
als Wahlhilfer machst du lieber
Briefwahl quasi, dass du die Briefwahl
auszählst? Ja.
Ist zwar dann mehr geraffelt,
weil du musst dann noch diese Briefe aufmachen und alles.
Ach, das macht dann vielleicht Spaß.
Nach dem dritten Papercut vielleicht nicht mehr, aber...
Also im Mai habe ich ja die Radeberger
Vorstadt ausgezählt, das hat keinen Spaß gemacht.
Da wählt jeder Brief.
Und jetzt
zur Landtagswahl war es halt schon mal nicht so schlimm,
weil es ja nur eine Wahl war und auch nicht diese
beschissene Kommunalwahl mit den 20.000 Kreuzen.
Oh ja, das hast du auch mal geklappt.
Und das Zweite,
was noch gut war, war, dass ich jetzt eine
ich glaube, Pönage-Vorstadt helst die.
Also hier zwischen Altstadt und
wo es dann Richtung Griesland-Manufaktur geht und so.
Da war
der Wahlkreis, wo ich zuständig war und da hatten wir
nur 500 Briefe. Also bei der Radeberger
Vorstadt waren es 800 Briefe und
doppelt, weil es ja zwei Wahlen waren, also 1700
und das war schon ein ganz anderer Workload.
Wir hatten richtiggehend eine Pause.
Ich weiß, dass ich dieses, das letzte Mal
Minuten an, weil ich schon gerne hingehe
und mir angucke, wie das ist,
ein cooles Ding, hinzugehen und vor Ort zu wählen.
Und diesmal
bin ich
vom Familienbesuch
schnell nach Dresden zurück
gerast.
Und war irgendwann halb zwei hier
und bin in die Schule gegangen zum Wählen.
Da war keine Sau mehr da.
In der Neustadt hatten wir bei den Kommunalwahlen letztens das Problem,
dass Leute, ich glaube,
15, 16 Uhr hingegangen sind und nicht mehr reingekommen sind,
weil sie über zwei Stunden angestanden haben.
Und ab 18 Uhr war halt Schluss.
Das darf aber eigentlich nicht sein.
Wenn man ansteht, dann mussten die noch alle durchlassen,
die anstehen.
Also es waren definitiv Leute da, die vor 18 Uhr kamen
und nach ewigem Anstehen nicht mehr reinkamen.
Und da gab es danach auch dementsprechenden,
also ich weiß nicht, wie berechtigt der Aufschrei war oder nicht,
aber es gab auf jeden Fall Leute, die sich arg darüber beschwert haben,
dass sie nicht zum Wählen kamen.
Und es ist ja bloß die Hälfte der früher kommen können.
Ich habe jetzt nicht die Wahlordnung vor Augen,
aber das ist ein echt legitimer Anfechtungsgrund.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das zu Ende gegangen ist.
Ich habe es noch gehört, wie es so neben...
Krass, krass, krass. Kritik gehabt danach.
Da würde ich fast schätzen, dass es einen Nachwahl geben könnte.
Das war ja nicht die Wahl jetzt erst, sondern davor.
Die Kommunalwahl das letzte Mal.
Naja, klar. Also jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich schon zu spät sein dafür,
aber das so für das nächste Mal, das für dich persönlich,
für einen legitimen Grund halten, das anzufechten vorm Verwaltungsgericht.
Es gibt ja wahrscheinlich sowieso Leute, die die Landtagswahl jetzt momentan anfechten.
Die AfD hat angefechtet.
Lass uns nicht weiter.
Weil es ja nicht stärkste Kraft geworden ist.
Ich habe ja sehr gelacht.
Ich hatte jetzt neulich in dem Zusammenhang irgendwie den Wikipedia-Artikel zur Bundestagswahl 20 Sitzen gelesen.
Und da war so ein Abschnitt Wahlbeobachter.
Und ich so, na du?
Klickst du drauf?
Und dann stand dann so, ja, die USZD hat auf Antrag der AfD Wahlbeobachter geschickt.
Zur Bundestagswahl halt.
Und der Endbericht war dann so, ja, also eigentlich ist alles hier super abgelaufen.
Aber was die AfD dann gemacht hat, war ziemlich komisch.
Die hatten halt Parteienfinanzierung, also Wahlkampffinanzierung über einen Verein abgewickelt,
damit sie das nicht melden müssen.
Ah, Witzbold.
Und das fand ich natürlich totale Pointe.
Schön, dass die halt die über einen umdacht.
Das zeigt dann, dass die neutral sind.
Ja, ja, genau.
Aber lass uns nochmal zurück zu deinem Podcast kommen.
Genau, wir sind jetzt abgeschliffen.
Das passiert immer, wenn ich einen Podcast zu besuchen bin.
Geh mal dazu.
Dafür sind wir hier.
Du hast, nur damit es nicht verschüttet geht,
wollte ich das noch erwähnt haben.
Also du hast meiner Meinung nach einen ausgezeichneten Kurz-Podcast,
möchte ich es nennen, gemacht,
nämlich den du hier auch schon akronomisierbar bei der Folge,
wo du selber mitgemacht hast, erwähnt hast,
nämlich gar nicht so einfach,
der eine erstaunliche
Produktionsqualität
hat. Du hast ja selber
gesagt, dass du sehr viel Zeit investiert hast, das irgendwie
möglichst nach NPR klingen zu lassen.
Das hat so ein bisschen diesen Storytelling-Auspekt.
Dieser Klang, der ergibt sich ja dann halt aus der Hardware, die du
verwendest. Ich hatte gesagt, bei Penta
habe ich dann diese Cloud-Computing-Folge gemacht, letzten Juni
und hatte dann die Folge darauf gleich
nochmal was gemacht, nämlich
I Love Unicode, was aber im Titel steht
als I Replacement Character Unicode.
Das hat übrigens überraschende
gebrochen bei uns. Das haben wir auch schon festgestellt.
Das können wir dann eventuell gleich noch mal als Anekdote
machen, aber sonst schreibe ich jetzt schon wieder ab.
Und da habe ich so gedacht, das ist ja
eigentlich schon eine richtig geile Sache.
Hast du das Blut geleckt?
Ja, genau. Da habe ich Blut geleckt
und aber es wäre eigentlich
cool, nicht nur so zu
sitzen und so, ja, was machen wir jetzt hier so?
Lass uns mal irgendwie plaudern, so irgendwie nach
drei Stichpunkten, die wir vorher gemacht haben, also das Format,
was wir auch hier quasi machen, sondern
es wäre auch geil, wenn irgendwie so ein bisschen was produziert ist
vorher und habe natürlich total verkannt,
dass wir in diesen 90 Minuten schon nicht genug Zeit haben
und dann noch Zeit rauszunehmen für noch was
anderes, ist ja vollkommen aussichtslos.
Aber daraus ist dann diese Idee für
gar nicht so einfach entstanden, was ich auch
tatsächlich ganze drei Monate durchgehalten habe,
monatlich zu machen.
Ja, immerhin. Aber die Folgen waren auch echt
informativ.
Es gab dann jetzt Anfang des Jahres noch eine Folge und ich habe auf der Liste jetzt mal
die nächste Folge zu machen, aber
wie gesagt, es ist halt
ein Investment, also es sind so für diese
acht Minuten, die man am Ende hört, also eigentlich
Ich plane nicht auch 10 Minuten, aber ich rede zu schnell.
Und dann hören die Leute das auch noch auf anderthalbige Geschwindigkeit.
Genau, oder Kielan hat auch dreifache Geschwindigkeit.
Ich weiß nicht, musst du bei mir dann runterdrehen?
Bei dir habe ich tatsächlich, glaube ich, einen Hauch runtergedreht.
Also es gibt so zwei, drei Podcasts, die ich für die einzelnen Podcaststellungen auf zwei, fünf runter bin,
weil ich da wirklich dann Wörter nicht mehr verstanden habe.
Aber das sind ja die Ausnahmen.
Ich hatte jetzt tatsächlich mal auf Twitter rumgefragt,
auf was für eine Geschwindigkeit hört ihr eigentlich akronomisierbar,
weil ich diese Schere im Kopf habe,
ach, die Musik möchtest du ja trotzdem nicht auf schneller Geschwindigkeit hören.
vielleicht spiele ich einfach die Musik
langsamer ab.
Das finde ich doof, dass du ein Podcast mit Musik.
Ich mache einfach die Musik
auf Dreiviertelgeschwindigkeit,
damit sie dann wieder normal klingt, wie die Leute
das anderthalbmal so schnell hören.
Da musst du halt verschiedene Feeds anbieten.
Akronomisierbar für 1,25-fach,
Akronomisierbar für 1,5-fach und so weiter.
Das ist fancy.
Ich fände es eigentlich schick, wenn man irgendwie einstellen könnte,
jetzt kommen irgendwie anderthalb Sekunden Musik.
Geht mal bitte,
jetzt kommt ein Stück Musik,
bitte macht mal wieder auf einfache Geschwindigkeit,
damit die Musik wieder original ist.
Die Chaos-Podcasts zum Beispiel, die hat Musik einbetten.
Das finde ich halt auch super unpraktisch, wenn man dann nicht
irgendwie einen Chapter-Mark hätte, das halt irgendwie
noch sagt, ich bin Musik und dann kann ich mein
Client... Aber die Chapter-Marks ja häufig auch
so ein paar Sekunden daneben sind.
Das ist ja egal, solange es halbwegs hinhaut.
Aber das Ergebnis war, dass viele Leute dann
geschrieben haben, ich hatte ja auch bei uns
im Matrix-Chat rumgefragt,
die meisten Leute haben gesagt, ich höre auch schon häufig
Podcasts relativ schnell, aber bei euch
wegen Kilian, das kann ich nur auf einfache Geschwindigkeit.
Sorry.
Mehrsich für anderthalbfach und das klappt eigentlich
relativ gut so für alles, da kann ich noch folgen.
Also zweifach
ist dann schon hart.
Man schraubt ja auch nicht instant hoch, sondern man
gewöhnt sich ja immer weiter hoch.
Ja, vielleicht kommt das irgendwann noch.
Wenn die Leute bei Aufwachen noch längere Folgen machen wir das.
Ich habe mir kannten, der ist blind, der hört alles auf
fünffache Geschwindigkeit.
Das ist, das kannst du, das
process ich nicht mehr. Das verstehe ich aber auch, dass du dann halt hin willst,
weil es halt viel mehr Informationen in kürzere Zeit rüberbringen
kann. Und gerade wenn du so Screenreader benutzt,
die halt auch das Ganze
über Ton machen und nicht über
fühlbare Ausgaben,
dann willst du das natürlich schnellstmöglich machen, weil du hörst
die Ui-Limente alle 20.000 Mal am Tag
dieselben.
Und ein weiteres Podcast-Projekt, was ich auch
ziemlich cool finde von dir, ist der
sogenannte Space Tourist.
Genau, das war dann mein weiterer
fehlgeschlagener Versuch, ein Format
zu entwickeln aus
den Produktionsbedingungen, nämlich,
dass ich dann festgestellt habe, gar nicht so einfach, scheiße, die Recherche
dauert so lange. Ich gehe einfach irgendwo in ein Interview,
Leute. Und ich habe natürlich überhaupt nicht dabei bedacht,
dass dieses Planen von Reisen
und sowas noch viel anstrengender ist, als einfach
sich hinzusetzen und irgendwie kurz von Wikipedia
ein paar Artikel zu klicken und das irgendwie in ein
schönes Skript zu gießen.
Davon gibt es bis jetzt zwei Folgen.
Das war in Halle, das war so,
da hatte ich auch übelst lange überlegt,
was ist denn jetzt so irgendwie die erste Folge, die man machen könnte?
Das muss ja irgendwie was Besonderes sein.
Das Konzept ist ja erstmal, dass du von Herkaspace zu Herkaspace
reist. Ja, genau. Und damit den Leuten
Quatsch, genau. Und du warst in Halle.
In Halle war das halt einfach, dass dann Honky, also
mein quasi Co-Moderator bei Penta Radio
und auch Co-Vorstand
beim C3D2 meinte dann so
hier, ich fahre jetzt am Wochenende nach Halle,
willst du mitkommen? Und ich so,
ja Moment, ich hole kurz mein Aufnahmegerät,
es geht los. Und das war dann die erste
Folge in Halle und das
zweite war dann, dass ich auf Dienstreise in Berlin war
und dann habe ich Ayubo von der Seabase angeschrieben,
den ich schon kannte, weil der auch ab und zu mal hier bei
uns in Dresden ist und
da haben wir ein kleines, nettes
Gespräch geführt.
Und ja, das ist alles so ein bisschen,
das ist halt so genau das
Gegenkonzept so gar nicht so einfach, weil das ist
total verpeilt und ins Blaue hinein.
Und am Ende bauen wir dann
irgendwie so ein Narrativ daraus, wenn wir dann die Sendung zusammenschneiden.
Hast du nicht zwei Folgen aus Berlin
gemacht irgendwie? War das nicht?
Das war die Folge
und das ganze Interview halt als Bonusfolge.
Achso, aha, okay, so war das genau.
Ja, ich habe es am Anfang
versucht, aus Akronomisierbar
was Kohärentes zusammenzuschneiden.
Ich habe es auch nicht so schnell aufgegeben.
Deswegen kriegt ihr das ganze
Gelaber hier einfach verbatim.
Nein, Quatsch, die ist natürlich richtig stark moderiert
und ihr hört nur die guten Ecken und alles
Genau, also eigentlich sitzen wir
jetzt hier schon seit 10 Stunden
Den ganzen Tag schon verplempert
Genau
Die deine Podcast-Namen sind by the way auch echt on point
Also wir haben uns ja für Akonomi
über echt überhaupt keine Ahnung gehabt
mal kurz davor den Podcast Naming Things zu nennen
nur weil das sehr hard ist
aber gar nicht so einfach und Space Tourist finde ich echt klasse
Ja, ich glaube
bei Space Tourist war auch der Name
dieser Wortwitz war das Erste, was stand.
Ah, nice.
Hier hast du einfach vorher ein Konzept gehabt.
Wir haben ja nicht, unser Konzept ist,
eigentlich,
mittlerweile hat es so ein bisschen so ein Interviewformat,
weil wir uns immer mal Leute einladen, die dazukommen
und über irgendwas Spezielles reden.
Das sind auch die Folgen, auf die ich mich
am meisten freue. Aber
warum nicht akronomisierbar? Unser Titel,
unser Sendungsname ist...
Ich meine, ich habe mich gewöhnt dran, aber ich verstehe.
Es gibt da kein Konzept dahinter.
Super Googlebar. Wir haben dieses Punkt
Bar als Domainname, eigentlich ist es
fest. Es gibt halt nichts anderes, was akronomisierbar heißt.
Nichts.
Gar nichts. Nichts anderes, was akronomisierbar ist.
Ja. Schade.
Ne, da ich jetzt gerade sehe, dass iReclassment Character
Unicode, diesen
Folgentitel von Penta Radio, das hat
ein System gebrochen, womit keiner von uns gerechnet hat.
Und zwar unseren Jahresbericht.
Scheiße. Aber ist das nicht noch
ein ASCII-Zeichen sogar?
Ne, ne, das ist ja hier
U plus
FFFD, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Ganz am Ende von der BMP.
Da siehst du, ich habe mich mit Unicode auseinandergesetzt.
Und zwar haben wir ja als Verein so einen Tätigkeitsbericht.
Das ist auch relevant, weil wir ja gemeinnützig sind.
Und man muss dann alle drei Jahre bei der Steuererklärung
dann noch so ein Stapel Formulare einreichen,
dass man weiter gemeinnützig sein will.
Und dann guckt dann das Finanzamt drüber und sagt,
ah, okay, seid nicht Attac, ja, das geht schon.
Traurig.
Ich hätte gerade fast einen Schluck Maden im Gesicht gehabt.
Ja, Timing.
Und ja,
dieser Tätigkeitsbericht,
da haben wir halt unter anderem auch drinnen stehen,
was wir alles für Radiofolgen und so gemacht haben,
die ganzen Folgentitel als Liste.
Und das wird dann am Ende gesetzt
innerhalb dieses Protokolls
in Mitgliederversammlung mit Lua Latech.
Weil das irgendjemand anfangs mal so
gemacht hat. Also ich würde jetzt mal spontan raten
Astro.
Hey, Lua Latech ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, genau. Und Lua Latech
hat halt anscheinend so eine Input-Phase,
wo es dieses Unicode-Parsing macht
und das ist halt dieses Lazy-Parsing,
wo er quasi alle Byte-Sequenzen
nicht erkennt, durch einen Replacement-Charakter ersetzt werden.
Und dann die zweite Stufe,
das eigentliche Latex-Teil
davon, hat dann
quasi eine Logik drin, dass jeder Replacement-Charakter,
der auftritt in seinem Input, als Fehler
anerkannt wird. Weil er geht halt davon aus,
dass das halt aus einer ungültigen Codierung kam.
Das hat keiner dran gedacht, dass das auch
legitim in dem Input-Fall sein könnte.
Ja, warum auch?
Da habe ich dann bei Secoho Flow geguckt,
wie man Lua La Tech dazu bringt,
einen Replacement-Charakter auszugeben.
Da habe ich dann das Kurzsnippet gesehen,
kurz gelacht und den Browser-Tab wieder zugemacht
und ein Fragezeichen draus gemacht.
Wie viel Zeilencode war es?
Naja, es war nicht so viel,
aber es war halt schon wieder so arkan.
Also ich habe ja auch ein Paket bei CETAN,
also bei dem Tech-Archive.
Wo? Nur für Replacement-Charakter?
Nee, für Klammern.
Zum
More Efficient Typesetting of Brackets.
Und das ist, glaube ich, insgesamt 20 Zeilen
lang, dieses Paket. Also gut, dadurch,
dass das bei solchen Latex-Paketen
immer mit der Dokumentation noch
enttangelt ist, ist es dann am Ende länger, aber
das File, was am Ende bei dir auf der Platte landet,
ist irgendwie 20 Zeilen lang.
Und ja, dadurch habe ich
auch diesen Badge an meinem Revers
dranstecken. Ich habe auch ein CETAN-Paket.
Ich habe mich auch noch bei mir im Hinterkopf
als die Person, die in meinen
Erstsemester-Matte-Vorlesung saß und live mitgetecht hat.
Das fand ich von ein paar Reihen weiter hinten immer sehr, sehr beeindruckend.
Genau, das hatte angefangen schon im Physikstudium damals.
Also ich hatte, ich habe da zwei Personen, mit denen ich quasi das ganze Physikstudium verbracht habe.
Der eine ist Jeffrey, der auch im letzten oder vorletzten Penta-Radio mit dabei war
und was über Machine Learning erzählt hat.
Den habe ich so in der ersten Woche getroffen im Englischkurs.
Also in diesem Englisch für Physiker, was man da halt pflichtmäßig belegen musste irgendwie,
um mal nachzuweisen, dass man Englisch sprechen kann.
English for Physicians.
Diese Fachwörter kennt man so in die
Inclining Slope, wenn man wie so einen Grafen liest oder sowas.
Und da habe ich Jeffrey kennengelernt.
Der saß da halt quasi in der ersten
Englischstunde mit seinem Ubuntu-Laptop.
Und da dachte ich so,
let's a like-minded spirit.
Den könnt ihr euch gerne in die Sendung holen,
weil in dieser Machine Learning-Serie-Folge,
da haben wir halt wirklich,
da waren wir nicht ansatzweise alles geschafft.
Also da könnt ihr gerne nochmal die technische Seite machen.
Penta Radio ist ja so ein bisschen
auch für die Allgemeinheit zugänglich oder zumindest
das ist ein Anspruch. Die habe ich letzte Woche gehört, jetzt wisst ihr,
wie ich ungefähr mit meiner Q hinterher bin.
Sehr gut.
Und die
zweite Person, das ist Felix,
den kennt ihr jetzt nicht, der ist auch nicht mehr
in Dresden, aber mit dem
spielen wir ab und zu mal über Mumble
irgendwelche Steam-Spiele oder sowas
und bleiben in Kontakt und
den habe ich wirklich getroffen
fünf Minuten vor meiner ersten Vorlesung.
Da saß ich auf dem Gang
und habe noch den letzten Anhalter-Roman gelesen.
Und das war halt sein Signal,
dass das ein Like-Minded Spirit ist.
Sehr cool.
Und ja, das waren wir drei halt.
Und wir haben dann quasi sofort angefangen,
alles auf Computer mitzuschreiben,
was wir so erlebt haben.
Und haben unter anderem ein epochales
Analysis-für-Physiker-Skript gebaut,
was über vier Semester geht
und über 300 Seiten hat.
Das ist bestimmt beliebt,
wenn dir das zuänglich gemacht wird.
Das könnt ihr auch in die Shownotes tun.
Das gibt es auf argis-skripte.org.
Also Arges wie Englisch Ages, aber halt A-G-E-S halt eher deutsch.
Minusskripte.org.
Das ist auch so eine Seite, die habe ich jetzt auch seit sechs Jahren nicht mehr angefasst.
Ich weiß, bei mir im Mathekurs gab es auch so ein paar Leute, die diesen Mathekurs geteicht hatten.
Das war aber, glaube ich, eine andere Gruppe.
Das war von Brunard die Vorlesung.
Das war halt sehr auf den...
Und gerade diese Analyse für Physiker, also vier Semester wirklich bei Professor Timmermann,
Das war halt eine absolut epochale Vorlesung,
weil dieser Mann hat die einfach zum 25. oder 30. Mal
dieselbe Vorlesung gehalten.
Und das ist einfach so eingeschliffen.
Der hat halt angeschrieben in einer wahnwitzigen Geschwindigkeit,
gleichzeitig geredet, noch erklärt und sowas.
Und dann die Tafeln waren halt auch immer so konzipiert,
dass halt wirklich eine Tafel so ein abgeschlossener Denkprozess ist.
Das ist cool.
Und es war halt wahnwitzig, dichte Informationen,
aber du konntest dem super folgen.
Das war auf jeden Fall eine meiner liebsten Vorlesungen.
und die ich noch dazu vier Semester leben durfte.
Also hier siehst du Kapitel 1 bis 38.
Das sind 337 Seiten.
Ja, genau.
Es hat mich übrigens auch überhaupt nicht überrascht,
auf dem vorletzten Kongress dich im Hacker-Jeparty zu sehen
und da die ganzen Latich-Fragen.
Natürlich ist das kein Problem.
Du hast einen Latich-Source für irgendwelche Formeln
und du sollst sie, glaube ich, berechnen im Kopf.
Ja, genau.
Also im Kopf-Type setzen.
Was ist eins?
Genau.
Fand ich großartig.
Fand ich sehr, sehr gut.
Und ja, also das war
tatsächlich, also das hätte auch
abgesprochen sein können, dass mir diese Kategorie gegeben wird,
aber das war halt
mein Glück,
dass man halt nicht vorher gewusst hat, dass ich teilnehme.
Ich denke mal, wenn es jetzt nächstes Jahr
wieder Hacker-Jepardy gibt und die jetzt halt wissen, mit wem
sie es zu tun haben, dann wird es halt irgendwie Kategorien geben,
wo sie gar keine Chance haben.
Ich wollte so ein paar Fragen einreichen.
Stefan Majewski, stell dir mal andere Fragen.
Genau.
In der Finalrunde dann extra Muster zu schreiben.
das hier nur
finalrunden. Ich habe sogar ein GitHub-Star,
kein GitHub-Star, aber ein anderes Projekt,
ein GitHub-Star mit reingeworfen,
technik.xyz für dich.
Da musst du in drei Minuten
Bilder von Formel gegeben und du musst in drei Minuten
so viele Techen, wie du kannst davon.
Das fand ich
krass für dich.
Und noch eins, weil ich das auch
letzte Woche entdeckt habe, das ist
latexcrossword.com?
Nee, Requex Crossword, nevermind.
Hat nichts mit Latex zu tun. Alles gut.
Ja, sieht auf jeden Fall witzig aus
aber das wäre jetzt natürlich blöd, wenn ich jetzt
drei Minuten lang hier nicht rede, weil ich dieses Spiel spielen
deswegen werde, ich trage mir dann nachher
Lass dich mal nicht erblicken
Wir haben dann halt angefangen, diese Vorlesung mitzutechnen
und das war am Anfang
war das so, wir waren halt drei Personen
das heißt, ich habe die Handmitschrift gemacht, damit man noch so ein Backup
hat zum Kontrollieren, dann habe ich dann halt nochmal Sichtkontrolle
gemacht, dass alles richtig ist
und die anderen beiden haben halt in den Notebooks
gesessen, haben mal Latech mitgeschrieben
und haben sich halt mal abgewechselt, also so quasi
macht die Innotafel und dann macht der Nächste die nächste Tafel
und dann sind Markierungen in den Source-Files
drin, mit denen wir dann von Hand gemerged haben.
Irgendwann haben wir das dann geupdatet
mit Gobby, was so ein
Netzwerkeditor ist.
Also quasi halt
mit einem LAN-Kabelbeet zusammengesteckt, weil
ein Wi-Fi war natürlich noch nicht zu denken
2007. Zumindest
nicht in der TU und zumindest nicht im
Musikbau.
Und waren es halt mit dem
LAN-Kabel direkt verbunden, mit statisch vergebenen
IP-Adressen und haben dann halt
einen Server aufgemacht und dann haben sie
da halt am selben Fall zumindest schon mal arbeiten können.
Das hat schon mal diesen Merch-Schritt weggemacht.
Und natürlich wurden wir da mit der Zeit auch besser darin.
Dann hast du halt manchmal, wenn mir das Problem jetzt
so ein neues Thema gibt, dass du dann erstmal mit drei, vier
Symbole nachschlagen musst, aber dann hast du halt auch
mittlerweile schon irgendwie Internet gehabt in irgendeiner
Form. Zumindest vielleicht
das eine Notdruck, was irgendwie die gute WLAN-Antenne
drin hatte und irgendwie über drei
Häuser wenden weg irgendwie
konnte das WLAN-Signal, was zum Fenster reingeweht
kam, noch aufgefangen werden.
Wenn der mal in der Fall ist, muss ich aber auch
die Techify konsultieren, um da sinnvoll
mitarbeiten zu können. Wie geht man da überhaupt vor,
wenn da jetzt plötzlich ein Zeichen angemalt wird?
Die Techify, genau. Da kannst du auf einem kleinen Canvas
zeichnen und der schickt dir hier eine Reihe von 20 Zeichen
vor, die dem ähnlich kommen.
Das ist ein sehr essentielles Tool,
wenn ich mal komplexere Dinge
versuche in LaTeX nachzuschreiben.
Wir sind jetzt alle nicht mehr an der Uni.
Benutzt ihr noch LaTeX?
Ja, klar. Man alle Briefe, die ich so rausschreibe.
Also einer im Jahr.
Ich habe eine Webseite, wo in den Sourcen LaTeX vorkommt.
Geil.
da habe ich mich sehr auf Arbeit drüber aufgeregt
auf Arbeit haben wir auch so eine Dokumentationswebseite
die auch so aus Markdown kommt mit so einem
Static Website Generator und da dauert die
Build-Pipeline 30 Minuten, weil der jedes Mal
von vorne irgendwie Ruby installiert, um dann
Ruby-Gam zu verstellen
Richtig, nee, Middleman
Ja, und
auf jeden Fall richtig furchtbar
und ich rege mich halt immer darüber auf, dass dieses Ding
30 Minuten dauert und währenddessen habe ich
einen Website-Renderer
für ein Projekt, über das wir vielleicht nachher
reden, was in fünf
Sekunden rendert und dabei läuft PDF-Latech.
Stark. Ich hatte halt das
Problem bei der Webseite, dass ich halt Grafiken einbinden
wollte, also so Grafen oder sowas.
Und wollte halt nicht
jedes Mal anfangen, um mir erst Dinge zu malen, weil ich kann ja
schon TIX, also so ein
Paket für Latech, was halt eine
programmatische Grafiksprache ist.
ja, und TIX
ist auch der Grund, warum ich jetzt auch im
Informatikstudium, also in meinem Zweitstudium,
dann die Mathematik einfach so mitschreiben konnte,
weil wenn die halt dann anfangen,
welche Graphen anzumalen,
wenn es um Grafentheorie geht oder sowas,
dann schreibe ich halt einfach eine Tix-Grafik.
Und das geht halt mittlerweile hinreichend schnell.
Also ich glaube, mittlerweile bin ich jetzt,
glaube ich, fast schon ein bisschen aus der Übung.
Ich bin auch in meinem Elektrotechnikstudium
ein sehr großer Freund von CircuitTix.
Das heißt, in dieser Abkürzung, glaube ich,
Certix oder so.
Da gibt es ein Fan davon geworden.
Das ist so ein Tix-Aufbauungspaket,
mit dem du Schaltkreise zeichnen kannst.
Super fancy. Sehr cool.
Ist es dann wirklich so, dass du dir das anguckst
und dann das einfach so hintippst
und dann sieht es genauso aus.
Also prinzipiell ist es nicht so komplex,
dass du das nicht hinkriegst. Also es geht auf jeden Fall.
Wenn es sehr komplex wird, wird es manchmal
ein bisschen unhandlich mit den Koordinaten zu handeln.
Also ich weiß, dass mir das ein paar Mal vorgeschlagen wurde,
als ich meine Diplomarbeit gemacht habe
oder allgemein arbeiten für die Uni geschrieben habe.
Ich habe versucht, LaTeX, soweit es geht,
zu vermeiden und habe
alles mit Pendoc gebaut
und dann Markdown geschrieben,
weil mir diese gesamte Syntax
und auch dann Tix
unwahrscheinlich arkane und veraltet
vorkam oder umständlich, aber
ich habe mir einfach wahrscheinlich nicht genügend Mühe
gegeben, merke ich gerade.
Ich hau mal die Tix, Dax noch mit in die
Shownotes, ein tolles Paket.
So was habe ich dann zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt meine
Bachelorarbeit, die ich in Informatikstudien gemacht habe.
Ja, schöner Binärbaum.
Das kann man dann halt damit machen und
das könnt ihr auch in den Shownotes
bedenken, das ist einfach github.com
slash majewski slash bachelor thesis.
Das habe ich auch, ich habe einfach so
auf mein, als ich
dieses File angelegt, habe einfach auf die
Vorderseite draufgeschrieben, wie diese Arbeit ist
unter Creative Commons lizenziert, so
as if I own the place und das hat auch keiner kritisiert.
Also es war bei Professor
Vogler am Lehrstuhl und
da ist auch der Source Code Link,
wo man es findet.
Ich habe mal den Link in die Uhr.
Also was
wir jetzt auf Arbeit angefangen haben, ist, dass wir
alle, weil viele auf
VS Code umgestiegen sind und so ein
plant UML Plugin installiert
haben und jetzt sehr viel Dokumentation gerade, was so
Sequenzdiagramme und Klassendiagramme angeht,
einfach mal eben in Markdown mit ins
Dokument mit reinspeisen?
Benutzt du sowas wie Tix für OML?
Naja, das ist halt das, was ich bei
dieser Webseite halt mache. Da habe ich halt auch Markdown,
aus denen die Seiten generiert werden.
Und ich habe dann halt einfach gesagt, wenn da ein Codeblock
ist, der als Sprachmarkierung Tix dran
hat, dann ist das halt Tix-Source-Code
und dann zieht das dann der Renderer raus
und
packt das dann halt in so ein
Wrapper, also in so ein
Seiten-Template halt rein, baut das Ganze mit PDF-Latech
und dann gibt es dann PDF2SVG.
Ich glaube, das ist bei Inkscape dabei.
Irgendwo ist es nicht dabei.
Und daraus wird dann SVG und das kann dann halt in die Seite
reingeklatscht werden, so wie du halt nochmal ein Bild
einbindest. Und das
läuft da halt einfach mit transparent als Teil
des Bauprozesses. Bei SVG habe ich festgestellt,
dass es dann allerdings
unterschiedliche PDF-Programme gibt, die nur
unterschiedliche Subsets von diesem SVG tatsächlich
darstellen konnten. Also da gab es SVG, was
zum Beispiel bei mir auf dem
bei Ocular, FKDE, gut aussah
und was dann, wenn ich es meinem Betreuer,
der ein Mac hatte, zum Gegenlesen
gegeben hatte, dann plötzlich nicht mehr
funktioniert hat. Deswegen
habe ich dann in einem, in meinem
Diploma-Bytes-Make-File
alle SVGs erstmal nach
hochauflösendem PNG umgewandelt
bevor ich es embedded habe.
Die SVGs, das war auch bei diesen
Argus-Skripten, da haben wir
SVGs gemalt, weil
gerade so Skizzen aus fernöffentlichen
Experimenten und sowas, da haben wir halt einfach dann auf dem
Extrablatt halt mitgemalt und halt so eine Notiz gemacht,
hier kommt Bildnummer sitzen hin und dann hat er das Blatt halt
irgendwie zehn Bilder mit drauf und
die hast du dann halt danach in Inkscape gemalt und
Inkscape konnte dann zu dem Zeitpunkt auch
schon als PDF speichern
und dann PDF einbinden,
in PDF, das geht, also mit PDF natürlich.
Stimmt. Da kannst du ein Clued Graphics machen
und dann PDF einfach reinschmeißen.
Das ist ziemlich cool. Und habt ihr dann,
hat euch das bei der Mathe-Vorlesung
dann auch geholfen oder müsstet ihr alles nochmal
Bei Mathe-Vorlesungen war das nicht so das Problem, da gab es glaube ich nicht so viele Grafiken, also vielleicht ein oder zwei.
Anders hat euch das geholfen bei Mathe, dass ihr dieses Skript dabei angelegt habt.
Achso, ich denke schon, weil man hat sich, das ist halt auch eine Art und Weise, sich intensiv mit den Sachen auseinanderzusetzen.
Es wird ja mal gesagt, man soll halt Handmitschriften machen und nicht einfach nur so einen Foliensatz ausdrucken, weil das dann einmal irgendwie durch das eigene Bewusstsein durchläuft.
Und das ist ja eigentlich auch dasselbe, wenn du halt irgendwie diese Formeln in diesen Text umwandeln musst.
in diesem Quellcode, dann geht es halt auch
einmal durch den Kopf durch und
das führt halt durchaus dazu, dass man
sich da relativ gut dran erinnert. Also ich hatte da
zumindest persönlich keine großen Probleme
damit, aber das kann jetzt natürlich auch
sowieso einfach eine Prädisposition sein,
die jetzt damit nichts zu tun hat.
Also ich würde mich auf jeden Fall sehr
eingeschränkt fühlen, wenn ich in so einer Vorlesung nicht mit dem
Notebook sitzen dürfte.
Das gibt es ja manchmal,
dass dann gesagt wird, hier sind Notebooks nicht erlaubt.
Ich kann natürlich Intentionen verstehen, aber
finde ich ein bisschen heavy-handed.
Ich finde, das läuft nur darauf hinaus, dass ein Professor
nicht glauben kann, was Studenten damit Sinnvolles tun.
Ich will auch nicht
in Zweifel ziehen, dass die meisten Studenten damit nichts
Sinnvolles tun. Ja, und wenn es so ist, dann ist es halt ihr Problem
und ihre Schuld. Aber das hat auch nichts damit zu tun, dass der
Professor sich dadurch angegriffen fühlen sollte.
Also es gab auch einige Vorlesungen, bei denen ich X-Moto
gespielt habe. Ja, passiert halt.
Wenn die Vorlesung lahm ist und man selber halt keinen Bock
hat, zuzuhören, dann ist es halt so.
Mir geht das tatsächlich so, ich kann nur
zuhören, wenn ich gleichzeitig irgendwie
haptisch beschäftigt bin.
So ein Fidget Cube dann dabei.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ich habe mir ein Fidget Cube,
mein Kollege Felix, der direkt neben mir sitzt, ist es genauso.
Das ist sehr witzig. Ich habe mir ein Fidget Cube
auf den Schreibtisch gelegt, weil ich bei Meetings
dann nicht abschweife, wenn ich irgendwas mit den Händen machen kann.
Da kann ich tatsächlich einen GitHub-Star
dazu geben und zwar ein Spiel,
das heißt Oh No, das ist,
könnt ihr mal die URL abtippen.
Ist das ein Fidget Cube fürs Handy oder
was ist das? Ja, das ist quasi ein Spiel.
Da musst du halt,
es ist halt quasi auch so ein einfaches Puzzle
wie so ein Sudoku in der Art.
Und das läuft halt mittlerweile bei mir
einfach total mechanisch. Also ich habe hier mittlerweile
so einen Totalscore von 2,45 Millionen.
Also ich habe irgendwie schon
weit über 100.000 Spiele gemacht.
Und das ist halt immer das, was ich mache, wenn ich
im Meeting sitze, weil die Hände brauchen halt was zu tun.
Genau. Und
das ist halt einfach so mechanisch, da denke ich nicht drüber nach.
Das mache ich einfach nur. Und dann haben die Hände
ihr Ding zu tun und ich kann dem Meeting folgen.
Auch auf dem Smartphone, weil da musst du
ja schon hingucken, um zu sehen, was du machst, oder?
Nein, das geht.
Zumindest, ich hatte mir diesen Fidget Cube geholt und irgendwann hat mein Kollege nur noch da mitgespielt die ganze Zeit, beziehungsweise der hat irgendwie mit dem Kugelschreiber geklickert und das Fieseste war, als er dann angefangen hat, den Kugelschreiber so subtil auf- und zuzuschrauben, weil da so ein ganz hochfrequentes Feature rauskam, wo ich irgendwie Gänsehaut gekriegt habe.
da habe ich ihn dann mehrmals, auch wenn er
gerade vor der Kamera stand im Meeting,
habe ich ihm einfach mittendrin diesen Kugelschreiber
aus der Hand gerissen und ihm stattdessen
meinen Fidget Cube hingetan. Danach hatte
er meinen Fidget Cube so häufig in der Hand, dass
ich ihm dann irgendwann einfach einen eigenen
Fidget Cube besorgt habe.
Nice.
Genau, wir waren
ja jetzt eigentlich noch dabei, was ich so mit
Medien mache. Genau.
Vor irgendwann vor zwei Stunden.
Backtracking.
Ich war dann im Dezember halt zum
Forschung gewählt worden und dann dachte ich dann so,
dann fühle ich mich jetzt halt
verantwortlich.
Und dann kam dann so im Januar
eine Anfrage vom MDR,
wo dann
so gefragt wurde, ja, das war genau,
das war diese Zeit gerade, als diese Bundestags-Leaks
waren. Das war ja letzten
Dezember, gab es ja diesen
komischen, pickligen Hacker, der da
im Keller seiner Eltern
sitzt und hat
so irgendeinen Twitter-Account übernommen
und hat dann da so Leaks
gepostet als Adventskalender. Also irgendwie so
heute Türchen 9 gibt es irgendwie einen Chatverlauf
von Claudia Roth oder sowas.
Und das halt irgendwie 24 Mal.
Das hat irgendwie kein Schwein groß interessiert. Und dann
irgendwie dann zwei Wochen später war anscheinend
irgendwie Slow News Day und dann hat das irgendjemand
gefunden und dann ist das halt total
eingeschlagen und alle
plötzlich total in Panik.
Und da war dann halt da eine Redakteurin
beim Sachsenradio da, die auf die Idee gekommen, machen wir mal
einen Ratgeber dazu, dass den Zuschauern
das vielleicht nicht passiert, dass sie irgendwie plötzlich
in der Öffentlichkeit stehen und was mit ihren ganzen Chatverläufen
und so. Und hatten dann halt
bei uns angefragt und dann habe ich mich dann
verantwortlich gefühlt, so als Vorstand kann man doch nicht
einfach Nein sagen, dann gehst du halt mal hin.
Und dann war ich dann da und das war
dann das erste Mal, dass ich dann ein richtiges
Radio, in Anführungszeichen, gesehen habe.
Und das war ja schon mal total faszinierend.
Das war auch total in die Hose gegangen wieder.
Es lief genauso flüssig wie
unsere Planung für den heutigen Aufnahmetermin.
Was? Also fantastisch.
Ja, genau.
Völlig reibungslos.
Denn die
gute Frau, die hatte mit mir am Telefon gesprochen,
dann hatte ich ja gesagt, ja, hier und so und so ist meine E-Mail-Adresse,
da können Sie mich nochmal anschreiben,
weil sie wollte mir halt noch so einen Fragenkatalog schicken,
damit ich mich vorbereiten kann.
Und sie meinte halt so, ja, das ist
auf eine Stunde angesetzt, wo ich auch schon so dachte,
okay, ja, gut, okay, krass.
Und
sie wollte mir einen Fragenkatalog schicken und dann kriege ich
keinen Katalog und nix und nix, aber ich wusste halt den Termin
und dann dachte ich so, dann gehst du halt einfach hin
und bin dann extra irgendwie halt
nicht nur eine Viertelstunde vorher,
sondern eine ganze Stunde vorher, damit man nochmal
im Zweifelsfall irgendwas reden kann.
Und kommen wir erstmal so rein,
dass erstmal total,
prinzipiell ist das dann, das ist hier
im Landesfunkhaus
Sachsen, Quatsch, ich will sagen, Dresden,
auf der Stauffenbergallee,
beim Militärhistorischen Museum, da ist ja so ein
Gebäude, wo auch
irgendwie Groß-MDR dran steht, da an der Seite.
Da komme ich ständig dran vorbei.
Ja, genau.
fahre ich tatsächlich relativ vollfriedig dran vorbei, wenn ich mit der
64 zum Hackerspace fahre.
Die fährt ja da oben
an der Staufenbackerle entlang.
Und da
komme ich halt so hin und es ist erstmal
so ein Newsroom in der Mitte, wo
halt irgendwie Redakteure sitzen und bauen irgendwelche Beiträge
und irgendwie telefonieren
irgendwie mit Leuten, die da irgendwie
Sachen liefern sollen und sowas alles und irgendwie der Typ,
der den Verkehrspunkt irgendwie vorbereitet
und irgendwie so ein Typ,
jetzt letztes Mal, als ich da war, war da so ein Typ,
der hat offenbar Telefondienst gehabt und hat dann
Hörertelefon gehabt.
Das würde ich in Sachsen auch nicht haben müssen.
Wo dann halt so die
durchschnittlichen Sachsen-Radiohörer anrufen und sagen,
was war denn gerade das letzte Lied für einen Sänger?
Das war Ed Sheeran. Ach du meine Güte,
wie schreibt man das denn?
Das ist E, E, Emil, E.
Okay, war toll.
Da hat jemand sehr viel Geduld,
offenbar. Oder lernt es gerade,
sehr viel Geduld zu haben?
Sehr coole Job.
Und da war dann halt auch ein Plätzchen,
wo ich dann hingesetzt wurde, wo dann halt die Telefonanlage
war fürs Hörertelefon.
Und dann hast du halt da so mehrere
Studios drumherum, weil die produzieren auch Beiträge vor.
Da hast du ja nicht nur ein Studio, da haben
sie fünf insgesamt und dann noch so ein Technikplatz,
wo dann die Sendeausspielung erfolgt.
Und ja, alle natürlich
sehr beschäftigt und alles.
Und an der Wand hängt so ein
großer Fernseher und da ist ein
Programm offen, also so eine Spezialsoftware
für Radioprogrammplanung,
wo halt der Sendeplan
drauf ist. Und
das fand ich halt total faszinierend, weil du hast
halt quasi diese Ankerpunkte alle
30 Minuten. Und wenn halt Nachrichten
für 11 Uhr geplant sind, dann kommen die Nachrichten
um fucking 11 Uhr 0 Sekunden.
Gibt es keine Diskussion, weil die kommen ja auch
im Zweifelsfall noch von irgendwo anders her.
Oder wenn es dann halt da die halbe Stunde ist, dann gibt es dann so
Regionalnachrichten, was dann irgendwie aus den Landkreisen
kommt und da müssen sie halt exakt 11.30
wegbranschen zu den ganzen Regionalsendern.
Oder wie Regionalfunkhäuser,
was dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie so in Kabuff ist, wo
ein Typ sitzt und spricht da eine Stunde diese
Regionalnachrichten ein.
darauf richtet sich halt alles aus
und dann hast du halt natürlich, Musik ist ja
auch nicht, dass da irgendwie die Moderatorin sitzt, ach, heute
spielen wir mal Whitney Houston, sondern die,
da gibt es halt auch eine Musikredaktion, die irgendwie
dafür sorgen, dass das halt irgendwie dem
Tageszeitpunkt angepasst ist und irgendwie auch dem
Sendeprofil entspricht, was dann halt für eine Mischung kommt.
Die haben halt eine Playlist für die einzelnen Sendungen.
Was ich immer spannend finde, ist, dass sie es hinkriegen,
das so aufeinander abzustimmen, auch schon beim Fernsehen eigentlich schon
immer, dass das eine wirklich Punkt
dann fertig ist, wenn
das nächste anfangen soll.
Ich meine, bei einem Film oder bei Fernsehsendungen,
die schneidest du halt auf die richtige Länge.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das bei Kinofilmen
im TV auch machen, aber...
Die schneiden die Werbung auf die passende Länge.
Und die Werbung wird auf die passende Länge gestimmt.
Kinofilme und sowas ist ja einfach, weil die wissen ja vorher,
wie lang die sind. Also so ein Lied, das wächst halt auch
vorher schon, wie lang es ist. Aber manchmal merkt man es halt
beim Radio, dass sie sich irgendwie verkalkuliert haben
oder dass sie sich irgendwie verquatscht haben
und dann brechen sie so ein Lied mittendrin ab
und sagen, jetzt muss die...
Musik ist ja auch relativ egal.
Genau, das ist ja halt
früher, als halt noch die Leute mit den Kassettendecks
da saßen, haben die Musik aus dem Radio aufgenommen,
haben sie sich ja mit drüber aufgeregt, dass die
Moderatoren dazwischen reinquatschen. Das machen sie aber extra,
ne? Das ist ja quasi die Fokus der.
Das machen sie heute noch bei den Radiosendern extra,
dass sie am Anfang von jedem Lied
nochmal drei Worte sagen, damit es quasi,
das ist genau wie bei den Filmen, wo oben rechts das
Fernsehsender-Logon zu sehen ist, muss es
irgendwie ein bisschen, das ist Absicht.
Ich kann über vermuten, es hängt einmal damit zusammen,
vielleicht, dass man keine Stille zwischendurch haben will,
dass es halt ineinander übergehen soll, damit es halt
diesen Klangteppich bildet, den du ja eigentlich haben willst
bei so einem Tagesprogramm, was ja wirklich
Hintergrundmusik sein soll. Aber es ist, glaube ich,
die Musik soll auch gebrandet sein, dass du
es nicht einfach verbatim
ohne Modifikation einfach abspielst.
Heute schneidet ja eh keiner mehr Radio mit, oder?
Nee, aber es ist immer noch so da,
wenn du selbst, wenn du dir so ein Webradio anhörst,
also bei so Sendern, die
so lokal produziert werden, sowas wie
Detektor FM, das machen ja auch eine
relativ kleine Gruppe von Leuten,
da ist das nicht, da spielen sie das einfach nacheinander ab
und da haben sie auch einen reinen Musiksender, wo nur
Musik läuft, ohne dass sie, glaube ich,
dazwischen die ganze Zeit irgendwas labern.
Aber zum Beispiel, was ich noch ganz gerne
höre, ist Deutschlandfunk Nova.
Hört ihr wirklich Radio oder hört ihr bestimmte Radio-Sachen
als Podcast?
Ich persönlich höre natürlich Radio.
Ich höre Deutschlandfunk Nova, das Update, und auch weil ihr das empfohlen habt
in eurer ersten oder zweiten Sendung.
Irgendwann mal, ja.
Ich glaube sogar in der 0. Sendung.
Boah, krass. Kann das sein, wo ihr so Podcasts aufgelistet habt?
Und das war halt gerade, als ich mit Podcasts anfing,
da hatte ich ja gerade euch abonniert und dann alles durchgehört,
weil ich bin jetzt so ein Completionist.
Ich höre einen Podcast nur, wenn ich ihn von null hören kann.
Ja, den finde ich auch schrecklich, wenn das nicht geht.
Also ich höre tatsächlich gerne Radio
einfach aufgrund dieser Kontrollabgabe,
so wie manche Leute auch gerne Fernsehen.
Beziehungsweise was angenehm ist,
vom normalen Fernsehen, dem guten alten Fernsehen,
auch wenn ich nicht mehr Fernsehe,
gegenüber, ich schaue mir alles gezielt,
dann ist das, dass du einfach mal abschalten kannst,
du sagst, mach jetzt irgendwas an
und dann nehme ich das halt auf.
Ja, das ist so der Vorteil.
Du musst nicht selber irgendwas kurieren und raussuchen.
Das ist natürlich auf einer mikroskopischen Ebene
bei Radio was anderes. Ich sage zum Beispiel,
ich mache jetzt morgens Radio an, das läuft
nebenbei, dann habe ich immer mal
neue Musikvorschläge oder die Nachrichten.
Das ist, was mir zum Beispiel bei Detektor FM
geführt hat, diese Nachrichtenbeiträge
zwischendurch. Das ist mir schon wichtig, weil ich meine gesamten
Nachrichten komplett über Radio
konsumiere.
Ich höre gar kein Radio.
Also ich höre ein paar Radiosendungen.
Wie konsumierst du Nachrichten?
Ich lese Dinge
im Internet und schaue hin wieder die Tagesshow als Podcast.
Das ist halt das Spannende, wenn man
Nachrichten nicht so als Erstformat irgendwie
mitbekommt, sondern halt so Twitter
liest und dann immer nur diese Zweitverwertung
quasi hat. Also man kriegt halt nur die Reaktion
auf die Nachricht mit und kann dann so reverse-engineeren,
worum es eigentlich gerade in den Nachrichten geht. Das ist immer sehr
witzig. Also beim Postelon ist das schon
wieder fast...
Die linken nochmal auf die richtige Sache,
damit man irgendwie verstehen kann, was jetzt hier gerade parodiert
wird. Aber ich bin zum Beispiel ein sehr
Audio-Fieler-Typ.
Das heißt, ich
finde es gar nicht mehr so entspannt, irgendwie was zu lesen,
weil ich den ganzen Tag lese, irgendwie auf Arbeit.
Und deswegen ziehe ich mir Nachrichten
gerne in Form von
Audiobeiträgen rein. Und dann
will ich nicht hingehen und mir irgendwie eine Nachrichtensendung
abonnieren, sondern, das habe ich auch,
ich habe tatsächlich irgendwie ein MDR
in meiner Podcastliste drin
und dann gesagt, hier, lad das mal runter
und füge das
automatisch in die Playlist ein.
Und wenn mich das Thema dann nicht interessiert,
dann gehe ich einfach zur nächsten und dann kommt wieder ein normaler
Podcastbeitrag.
Ich habe irgendwie so mal als Quip gebracht,
dass ich ja nur Podcasts abonniert habe,
in denen ich mal zu Gast war.
Und das trifft tatsächlich auf die meisten
von diesen Podcasts meine Liste zu.
Also natürlich, ich habe irgendwie die Feeds
von meinen eigenen Podcasts drin,
hauptsächlich so, damit ich sehe,
ob das RSS sich richtig geupdatet hat.
Und da trifft es natürlich trivialerweise zu.
Genauso bei Penta Radio.
Das höre ich jetzt natürlich auch nicht mehr,
weil ich war dabei, als es produziert wurde.
Und ich habe es im Zweifelsfall auch nochmal abgehört,
wenn ich dann die durchgehört habe
in die Kapitelmarken gesetzt habe und sowas.
Das heißt, du darfst jetzt endlich akronomisierbar hören.
Das stimmt halt nicht immer.
Also bei Alternativlos war ich auch noch nicht zu Gast.
Und beim Deutschlandfunk-Uver-Update auch noch nicht.
Aber du warst beim Aufwachen-Podcast zu Gast,
habe ich jetzt rausgehört.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wie kam es denn dazu?
Na, das war so ein Intro-Intro.
Das kannst du halt einfach einschicken.
Also das Intro ist ja das, was Tilo produziert,
wo er Dinge zusammenschneidet mit der Titelmusik und alles.
Und irgendwann haben sie ja mal damit angefangen,
weil sie ja am Anfang mal sagen wollen, diese Folge wird präsentiert
von Name des Präsentators.
Haben sie dann irgendwann angefangen, dass sie von den Zuhörern Intro-Intros nehmen,
was dann halt quasi diese Folge wird präsentiert von
halt noch ein bisschen künstlerisch ausgestaltet ist,
wo dann Leute irgendwie Raps oder sowas machen.
Ist das irgendwie was Radio Lab das Ende macht oder was?
Da hast du ja irgendwie zusammengeschnitten.
Aber NPR macht das, dass du einsagen könntest,
diese Folge wurde produziert und zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo du das hörst, könnte schon alles nicht mehr aktuell sein
und dann schneiden sie das aktuelle Zeitung.
Ich kenne den Aufwachen-Podcast nicht.
Aufwachen-Podcast, den habe ich ein, zwei Mal gehört.
Ich muss sagen, der ist mir zu hart.
In die Ferne, was heißt das?
Das ist Thilo Jung, kennst du ja wahrscheinlich.
Und Stefan Schulz.
Früher war der FATS-Redakteur, ist jetzt freier Journalist
und macht hauptsächlich diesen Aufwachen-Podcast
und sein eigenes Talkradio und schreibt halt noch Bücher nebenbei.
Weil mir nicht so klar ist, wie man das als Einzelperson schaffen kann.
Für mich ist das eine Wochenaufgabe,
denen ihre Wochenoutput zu hören.
Es ist mehr so ein Get Woke-Stand, sei gerade munter.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist kein Aufwachen-Podcast.
Also Aufwachen so wie Wach auf Bürger.
Das ist so Medienkritik.
Also der Folie ist Aufwachen und Nachrichten gucken.
Und die haben halt, die gucken quasi Heute-Journal und Tagesthemen und sowas alles
und Nordmagazin und Sachsenspiegel und so
und kommentieren das dann halt irgendwie so natürlich einerseits
irgendwie von einem politischen Standpunkt, von wegen, dass das halt hier...
Aber in einem unwahrscheinlich brachialen Format,
Auf die Art und Weise, du hast ja gesagt, das ist irgendwie drei bis vier Stunden lang.
Dann geht es irgendwie am Anfang damit los, dass wir erstmal jeden einzelnen Spender und Unterstützer des Podcasts aufzählen.
Ich saß auf dem Kongress in dieser Podcaster-Podiumsdiskussion, wo der eine von Methodisch Incorrect saß und auch der Stefan Schulz.
und noch irgendjemand anders.
Und mir ist aufgefallen, der hat irgendwie eine andere
Herangehensweise, als ich einen Podcast
habe, muss ich sagen.
Ich finde den Podcast ein bisschen anstrengend.
Naja, das ist schon eine ernste Sache.
Das ist auch jetzt irgendwie ein wesentlicher
Cornerstone meiner Nachrichtendiät geworden.
Das ist auf jeden Fall
dadurch...
Ich würde ja gerne sowas haben,
halt nochmal quasi als Realitätsupdate
nochmal aus einer
eher rechten Perspektive. Also jetzt nicht von wegen
ich will jetzt keine Nazis oder sowas hören, aber jemand, der
diese nicht-linken
Positionen sauber verargumentieren kann.
Das stimmt, das ist irgendwie, das fehlt.
Die Leute, die auf die NPD
wählen, wo die ihre Informationen
herbekommen und so ist das schwierig.
Es gibt halt wahrscheinlich diese Leute, die halt nur noch AfD bei Facebook
lesen und die sind halt two far gone und
die anderen Leute sind halt wahrscheinlich dann halt eher
so die Leute, die noch bei der FAT sind.
Aber was wären die Leute, die jetzt, keine Ahnung,
60 sind und AfD wählen, was
konsumieren die
als Nachrichten, damit die so
eingependelt werden.
Die Bild.
Das reicht doch nicht, oder?
Ich würde sagen, dass es viel die Facebook-Bubble ist.
Aber ja, ich stecke
da nicht drin in so einer Sache.
60-Jährige, die Facebook lesen?
Ja.
Okay.
Das ist ein alte Leute-Netzwerk gefühlt.
Ja, ich meine, die haben irgendwann mal
von ihren Kindern ein iPad geschenkt bekommen.
Und hier ist dieses Facebook.
Da kannst du sehen, wenn wir irgendwelche
Bilder von den Kindern posten.
Und wenn du zweimal das falsche Likes hast, ist es umgekippt quasi.
Ja, das stimmt.
Genau, ich war ja gerade dabei, wie ich beim MDR war.
Genau, reden wir mal über was Schönes.
Genau.
Tiefe zu.
Ich sehe halt diesen Bildschirm mit diesem Sendeplan
und da ist halt schon die Musik drin
und dann sind halt so Beiträge drin,
so wie Werbung oder vorproduzierte Sachen
oder Teaser oder sowas und die haben halt alle ihre Sekundenzahlen dran stehen.
Und das war mir erstmal in dem Moment
so richtig klar geworden, dass das halt einfach ein Format ist,
was auf die Sekunde geplant ist, weil dann sind halt zwei Lieder.
Das ist so eine Art Gant-Diagramm oder wie darf ich mir das vorstellen?
Nee, einfach so eine Liste.
Wenn du was hinzufügst, siehst du, dass das Hinterstand dann schon so lange dauert.
Ja, also quasi die Redakteurin, die ich da hatte, bei der ich da saß, die da für den Ratgeber zuständig war,
die hat halt dann quasi die Schreibansicht auf diesen View und kann dann halt da Beiträge einpflegen
oder kann halt sagen, der Beitrag ist zum Beispiel 2,30 Uhr lang anstatt zwei Minuten und sowas.
Und dann muss natürlich dann halt wieder diese Summe stimmen, dass halt 11.30 Uhr wieder genau 0,0 ist.
Und dann siehst du halt wirklich diese ganzen Programmpunkte und dann siehst du halt zum Beispiel da so zwei Lieder stehen
und dazwischen ist halt so ein Programmpunkt Ansage
und der ist halt einfach sieben Sekunden lang.
Da musst du wissen, was du sagst.
Genau.
Geplant.
Dann meint sie so, ja, wir haben ja noch ein bisschen Zeit,
dann gehen wir einfach mal ins Studio rein.
Und ich so, ja, aber das ist doch gerade Sendung.
Ach komm, da ist doch die ganze Zeit Musik.
Und er ist halt aus und dann gehen wir so rein
und die Moderatorin auch eine freundliche,
so Größenordnung 40, 50 in der Altersklasse halt,
also vielleicht noch ein kleines bisschen jünger als ihre Zuhörer,
aber so, ne.
und total freudig
und extrovertiert und alles.
Und ja, hallo, schön, erklären wir mal so ein bisschen,
was hier los ist. Also es ist auch so im Wesentlichen,
wie ihr das schon mal im Colorado gesehen habt, also halt so ein
Selbstfahrerplatz, wie das
dann heißt, also wo der Moderator
selber die Pegel vor sich hat,
anstatt dass da noch so ein Extra-Techniker steht, der dann die,
die meinten dann auch so, ja,
das waren ja alles so Leute, die haben dann schon zu DDR-Zeiten
teilweise angefangen. Und
früher war das dann halt so, dass dann halt der Moderator halt nur
sein Mikrofon hatte und daneben war halt der Techniker,
der dann halt die Pegel hatte und der dann halt ganz schnell die Bänder gewechselt hat.
Nämlich nicht cool.
Und der dann halt gestikuliert hat, dass der Moderator jetzt nochmal irgendwie zehn Sekunden länger reden muss,
weil das Band gerade nicht rein will.
Und solche Sachen gibt es halt heutzutage nicht mehr.
Das ist halt auch dieselbe Software.
Also quasi dieser Screen, der da halt groß war im Newsroom,
das war halt einfach die Ansicht, die die Moderatorin da drin hat,
wo sie dann irgendwie sehen kann, jetzt als nächstes kommt da dieses und dieses Lied,
dann kann sie irgendwie da schon mal auf Vorhören drücken und dann ist es auf ihren Kopfhörern,
dann kann sie sich schon mal anhören, wie das Lied anfängt,
dass sie sich noch dazu eine passende Anmoderation überlegen kann.
Und dann erklärt sie mir gerade so alles.
Und so mitten im Satz, wie er so aus ihr rausblubbert,
was da alles so irgendwie abgeht und was ich zu beachten habe und sowas.
So mitten im Satz, ich muss mal kurz moderieren.
Setzt sie ihre Kopfhörer auf, dreht sich um, drückt auf diesen roten Knopf,
die Pegel fahren hoch und in einer völlig anderen Tonlage
redet sie plötzlich diese Radioansage rein.
Und da war ich sehr geflasht davon.
Was ist ein Switch?
Es ist wahrscheinlich genau dasselbe, wie wenn
irgendwie so ein Junior-Developer
neben mir sitzt und ich rede so mit dem über
irgendwas und ich muss kurz hier eine
Parklein anstoßen oder ich muss
kurz hier diesen Bug fixen und schaltet plötzlich
kurz um, macht das und dann schaltet
ein komplett anderen Modus. Ja, das war halt bei ihr genauso.
Die sagt halt einfach diese 8-Sekunden-Ansage
an irgendwie,
ja, hier ist Sachsenradio, gleich die Nachrichten
und jetzt kommt noch sowieso, tralala, ich weiß
ja nicht, aus mir kommt sowas nicht so flüssig raus
und drückt halt
den Knopf, die Pegel gehen wieder runter, sie nimmt den Kopf
und rede einfach genau an derselben Stelle weiter, wo sie vorher mit mir
geredet hat. Wie cool.
Und ja, und dann habe ich
dann auch erfahren, das war, das ist natürlich,
da das halt so ein Tagesprogramm ist,
heißt eine Stunde Ratgeber nicht, dass ich eine Stunde lang
reden muss, sondern das sind halt dann
so Blöcke von so zwei, drei Minuten
und davon halt vier in der Stunde verteilt.
Das verrät sich ziemlich gut, wenn du auf
Deutschlandfunk Nova die
eine Stunde History mal als Podcast abonnierst.
Das sind nämlich, glaube ich, genau 20 Minuten.
Zwischendurch ist es irgendwie Musik
und Nachrichten und Füller.
und genau
dadurch verdünnt sich dann alles so ein bisschen
und die hatten mich halt für so einen Ratgeber
Internetsicherheit eingeladen und das heißt halt
also sie hatten mir dann diesen Fragenkatalog
gezeigt, den ich nicht bekommen hatte
weil sie mir ihre E-Mail-Adresse falsch geschrieben hat und da war ich
erst mal auch wieder erschlagen, weil das waren so ungefähr
60 Fragen
also so drei Bildschirmseiten
Wie viel Zeit hattest du zu dem Zeitpunkt noch, bis du dann auf Air warst?
Ja, so 25 Minuten
Ach, schau
Das waren halt alles so klassische Fragen
wie oft sollte man ein Passwort wechseln und solche Sachen.
Also was wir alle aus dem Spielgraf wahrscheinlich beantworten können.
Da gibt es conflicting opinions.
Ja, das muss man einfach mal überzeugend vertreten, die eigene Position.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Und dann ist es halt so weit, dann gehe ich halt so zum ersten Block da rein
und stelle mich da halt auf diesen Gastplatz,
wo halt sonst die Nachrichtenbrecherin steht.
Und ja, das vorige Lied läuft halt gerade noch.
und dann sagt der die Moderatorin so, ja, wir fangen jetzt erstmal an mit dem und dem Thema
und dann reden wir nochmal kurz über Passwörter und dann sind wir zwei Minuten auch schnell herum.
Und ja, okay, kriegen wir hin.
Und ich hatte so ein Bedenken, weil du siehst ja, wie ich Monologe halte.
Ich kann halt, wenn ich ein gutes Thema habe, dann rede ich einfach so.
Man muss sich manchmal etwas zügeln, merke ich hier gerade.
Ja, genau.
Und ich habe halt totale Panik gehabt, dass ich in diesen zwei Minuten nichts gesagt bekomme,
weil ich einfach erstmal auf drei Anekdoten ansetze.
Aber ich habe dann halt festgestellt, in dem Moment, wo es dann halt wirklich losgeht
und ich habe ja dann auch diesen Screen vor mir
mit diesem Zeitplan und ich sehe halt diese
Sekunden erbarmungslos runterticken.
Genau.
Ich zeige dir mal gerade hier in meinem Aufnahmeprogramm
die Uhr.
Das sind doch erst eine Stunde, 20 Minuten.
Und man sieht halt diese Sekunden erbarmungslos
runterticken und plötzlich funktioniert man.
Plötzlich kriegt man es hin,
in Soundbytes zu reden.
Zumindest ich. Das passt doch eigentlich zu der
Aussage, ein Projekt dauert immer
genauso lange, wie man Zeit
gegeben bekommt dafür. Ich dachte, das ist heute
mal doppelt so lange. Plus irgendein
Faktor X. Ich sage nicht, dass es
hinterher fertig ist. Achso, okay.
Projekte sind quasi gasförmig.
Sie nehmen den Container an.
Genau. Wenn du jetzt gesagt bekommst,
du sollst jetzt das machen, du denkst dir,
ich brauche dafür drei Tage und die sagen,
ja, du kriegst jetzt drei Monate, dann schaffst du es irgendwie
drei Monate, daran zu arbeiten.
Ist ja schon. Meine Mutter hat
erzählt, sie hatte nach der Wende
als,
sie war vor der Wende in der Polizei und nach der Wende
hat die Polizei offenbar nicht mehr so viele Stellen gebraucht.
und dann ist sie gewechselt in die Buchhaltung.
Dann war sie bei einem Baustoffunternehmen,
hat sie in der Buchhaltung angefangen und dann wurde quasi
ihr so gegeben, ja, sie müssen jetzt hier die Gehaltsabrechnung
machen und das dauert halt einen Monat.
Oder beziehungsweise, das wurde ihr nicht gesagt,
es wurde ihr gesagt, wir machen jetzt als erstes die Gehaltsabrechnung
und dann so nach fünf Tagen kommt sie halt an
und sagt, okay, fertig, was jetzt.
Und der Chef guckt sie so unglaublich an,
wie war es jetzt, das ist ihre ganze Aufgabe,
das dauert einen Monat.
Nee, ich bin aber fertig.
Aber das hat einen Monat zu dauern.
Das hat sie einfach nicht gewusst, dass die Vorgängerin
einfach vielmals so lange gebraucht hat.
Das hört man aber häufig, dass man irgendwie jemanden beerbt und der
dann wesentlich länger für eine
Aufgabe gebraucht hat, die man mittlerweile einfach ganz
anders angeht und dann
wesentlich schneller auch ausführt. Ich habe mich
neulich mit einer
Kollegin von meinem Vater unterhalten,
die zwei altere
Mitarbeiter beerbt hat und sich gewundert hat,
warum die so lange für diese eine Aufgabe
gebraucht haben, die sie da gemacht haben.
In der Neuzeit schreibst du aus Versehen ein Shell-Script,
dass dein Arbeitsplatzwerk optimiert.
Das kannst du nicht nur machen, das darfst du nur keinem sagen.
Du hast nicht diesen einen Typen, der
seinen Arbeitsplatz selbst
outsourced hat nach Indien für sein halbes
Gehalt und einfach...
Für ein Fünftel-Gehalt. Er hat 100k
verdient und hat er für 20k so einen
Chinesen sich angestellt und dem das Security-Token
per Post geschickt. Und das haben
dann irgendwann die Firma mitbekommen, weil sie Andor &
Logins aus China gesehen haben, die aber gültig waren.
Aber diese Idee dahinter, fantastisch.
Ich muss aber
dazu sagen, wir haben auch noch
eine Stelle auf Arbeit, wo wir einen Release-Plan
als Wiki-Seite haben.
wo du einfach gewisse Häkchen setzen musst
manuell und das ist, jeder der das macht
kotzt darüber ab, dass das
manuell zu machen ist und warum dann nicht schon längst
ein Chill-Skript draus gemacht hat.
Kann man da vielleicht endlich mal gewisse Teile davon automatisieren?
Da könnte man endlich mal was automatisieren,
wenn man Zeit hätte, wenn man nicht die ganze Zeit manuell
released. Die Frage ist halt, es lohnt sich halt
auch nicht einen Task zu automatisieren, der drei Minuten
pro Monat dauert, wenn das Automatisieren um
so und so viele Mannwochen dauert.
So ein wunderschöniges Case-CD-Suit,
der ist schon ein Graf mit der Optimierungskurve,
wann sich die Automatisierung lohnt und wie viel Zeit man in die Automatisierung steckt.
Und dass man tatsächlich dann Monate mit der Automatisierung beschäftigt ist.
Aber das Tollste.
Wir, gerade wir neigen ja dazu.
Hm?
X-Case-ID 1-2-0-5.
Gerade wir neigen ja dazu, auch häufiger mal was zu automatisieren oder ein Skript zu schreiben.
Dieses gesamte Tool, was ich für das ASCII geschrieben habe.
Der Invoicer?
Der Invoicer.
Das ist, glaube ich, jedes Mal, wenn ich für das ASCII eine Rechnung machen musste,
habe ich es gekotzt
und weil es irgendwie
ein Word-Dokument war, dann habe ich irgendwann
angefangen zu Jackshaven.
Das ist ja quasi das, was das dann länger macht.
Habe einen Converter für
YAML nach Latex gebaut und dann irgendwann
Verwaltung für Projekte und dann
jedes Mal, wenn ich eine neue Rechnung schreiben musste,
habe ich erstmal drei Stunden irgendwie
darin investiert, dem Tool
die nächste Tätigkeit, die ich jetzt eigentlich nicht selber
durchführen möchte, beizubringen,
um sie dann mit dem Tool auszuführen.
Ich habe jetzt gerade, als ich auf XKCD
jetzt gerade gegangen bin, dass mich mein Firefox
jetzt darauf hinweist, dass
more than 500.000 Accounts from XKCD
were compromised in 2019.
Check Firefox Monitor to see
if yours is this.
Das war jetzt vor ein paar Wochen erst.
Das Witzige daran war, dass...
Das hat mich zwei überrascht.
Das andere war, das Geilste daran war,
dass das zweithäufigste Passwort
ist Crack Horse Battery Staple.
Das war nicht großartig.
Das hätte man irgendwie kommen sehen können.
Das haben die Leute aber, glaube ich, dann noch nicht so ernst genommen.
Ich glaube, ich hatte sogar einen Account damals, als ich noch in der Physikfakultät war.
Weil ich hatte fast zwei Jahre meine Diplomarbeit geschrieben.
Ja, ich dachte fast zwei Jahre im XCity-Forum zugebracht.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Also das waren die zwei entspanntesten Jahre meines Lebens.
Und ich ärgere mich auch zu Tor, dass ich da nicht viel produktiver war in dieser Zeit.
Weil das war ein super Leben.
Also eigentlich ist die Diplomarbeit damals auf ein Jahr ausgelegt gewesen.
Was auch schon ziemlich lang ist.
Was auch schon stattlich ist.
Ja, ja, es waren am Ende auch nur 70 Seiten oder so, was ich abgegeben habe.
und
allerdings darf man die erst anmelden,
wenn man alle Diplomprüfungen hatte
und ich hatte halt so eine Diplomprüfung,
die ich mit zwei Prüfern gemacht habe und die haben
sich ewig nicht auf den Termin einigen können
und ich hatte halt schon angefangen gehabt, an meiner Diplomarbeit
zu arbeiten, bis das dann irgendwann mal
ich tatsächlich anmelden konnte und habe das natürlich ausgenutzt.
Ich habe dann irgendwie fast
20 Monate an dieser Arbeit dann gesessen am Ende
und das war
extrem entspannt damals. Also dann war so
mein Tagesablauf so, dass ich dann so um neune
irgendwie so klingelt der Wecker und dann so, ja,
okay, das ist jetzt auch eher so ein Vorschlag als
irgendwie eine Pflicht oder so.
Dann habe ich dann erstmal wie so ein bisschen
Fernsehen angemacht und dann
kam dann bei Phoenix vielleicht so eine
Bundestagsdebatte, wo man sich erstmal noch so ein bisschen
einbüllen lassen konnte und dann so um 10, ja, so,
jetzt können wir da so mal aufstehen
und irgendwie ganz entspannt Frühstück essen
und dann fahren wir mal zur Uni.
Und dann bin ich so um 11 da und dann denke ich so,
okay, aber jetzt lohnt es sich ja eigentlich auch nicht mehr,
vorm Mittagessen groß was zu machen. Dann gehst du dann zum
Mittagessen mit der Arbeitsgruppe.
Dann muss man Pause machen vom Essen.
Genau, dann liegt es erstmal schwer im Magen,
erst erstmal Fressnarkose und dann so um 14 Uhr denkst du,
ich kann nicht so was machen.
Also das Physikstudium hast du aber tatsächlich zu Ende gebracht.
Das klang vor und so.
Ich habe beide Physikstudien zu Ende gebracht,
also Physik und auch Informatik danach.
Ah, Respekt.
Also ich bin Dippel Füß und Bachelor of Science.
Respekt.
Und war insgesamt elf Jahre studieren
und ich trauere dem Semesterticket weiterhin hinterher.
Ja, ja.
Das war echt eine schwere Umstellungsphase,
als ich dann das Semesterticket, die ich mal hatte,
und dann stattdessen halt so eine Abo-Monatskarte mir geholt habe.
Und muss dann halt, bis ich das mir gelernt habe,
dass ich halt daran denken muss,
dann so einen Anschlussfahrschein zu lösen,
wenn ich mal außerhalb rausfahre.
Ja, das ist so nervig.
Das war mir immer wieder passiert.
Also meine Brüder wohnen bei so einer Ecke Koswig.
Und da fahre ich dann halt mit der S-Bahn bis nach Koswig
und lasse mich dann das letzte Stück entweder mit dem Auto holen
oder ich laufe dann halt.
Und das ist mir so oft passiert,
dass ich irgendwie mit der Straßenbahn zum Bahnhof Mitte gefahren bin,
bin dann in die S-Bahn eingestiegen.
Und dann bin ich eine Station später am Bahnhof Neuschal panisch ausgestiegen,
hab den Entwerter gesucht, um diesen Fahrschein noch zu knippsen,
bin wieder in die S-Bahn eingestiegen.
Ich finde das echt schade.
Also es ist fantastisch, dass das Semesterticket hier in Sachsen,
den das ganze Bundesland abdeckt mit S-Bahn und ÖPNV.
Ich glaube aber nur in Dresden, aber nicht in anderen Städten.
ÖPNV in ganzem VVO.
In ganzem VVO, ja okay, VVO, ja, aber nur VVO.
Ja, nur VVO.
Also, also zu meiner Zeit, als ich damals angefangen habe,
Das ging nur bis Riesa.
Das kam dann erst so 2008 oder so,
dass man es in ganz Sachsen einsetzen konnte.
Nee, das gab es sogar noch später.
Sie hatten noch die dumme Regelung, dass du nur bis zur letzten Haltestelle
in Sachsen, aber nicht bis zur ersten Haltestelle außerhalb
fahren durftest. Da habe ich ein paar Mal mit dem Schaffner gestritten,
als ich nach Ingolstadt gefahren bin
und das Ticket erst ab Blauen gelöst habe.
Nee, erst ab Hof.
Mein Bayern-Ticket erst ab Hof.
Und diese
5-Minuten-Strecke dazwischen waren
offiziell nicht abgedeckt, damit sie irgendwann geändert hat.
Ich habe es gelesen,
ich weiß nicht, an welchem Kontext
war ich mir auf der VVO-Webseite und da stand drauf,
dass sie jetzt dieses Jahr irgendwie
so eine Übergangsregelung angeführt haben zwischen VVO
und MDV, weil zwischen O-Schatz und RISA
dass es halt dann so eine Spezialregelung
gibt, dass man halt nicht noch ein DB-Ticket
für diese eine Station lösen muss. Das ist generell alles so
kompliziert, jetzt wo ich ja auch mit in der Branche arbeite.
Ticketsysteme sind so, oder generell
das, was sie da machen, das ist alles so
unglaublich kompliziert. Ich dachte, die benutzen
einfach alle eure App. Ja, genau, schön wäre es.
Dann müssen wir noch mehr davon abdrehen.
ich höre Komplexität, wollen wir über meinen Arbeitgeber reden?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, du hast ja jetzt
glücklicherweise ein Büro, relativ schön zentral
in der Stadt, das ist nämlich irgendwie bloß 100 Meter von meinem Büro
entfernt, das werde ich da manchmal bei dem Hörerwurststand
rumstehen.
Was machst du denn jetzt?
Möchtest du darüber etwa reden? Ich bin bei dem großen
blauen Trapez, bei dem
ich glaube tatsächlich, das ist nicht mittlerweile der größte
deutsche Sachs-Konzern oder sowas?
Großes blaues Trapez?
SAP. Ah, das Trapez.
Es ist immer total witzig, wenn
wenn ich irgendwie in einem Freundeskreis oder Familienkreis oder so
jemandem sage, ich arbeite bei SAP.
Und sofort fangen alle Leute an zu stöhnen.
Oh Gott, ja, ja, da muss ich immer meine Lohnkostenabrechnung und sowas machen.
Jeder stöhnt im SAP.
Wir haben auch ein SAP-Tour über das wir kotzen.
Ich habe davon absolut keine Ahnung.
Also ich verwende ein SAP-System auch um meinen Urlaub einzutragen.
Weil natürlich hat SAP intern auch ein SAP-System,
was die ganzen Geschäftsprozesse macht.
Aber das ist halt so alles, was ich an Kontakt damit habe.
Also ich habe halt diese paar Selbst-Service-Formulare,
wo man irgendwie den Reisekostenzuschuss beantragt oder sowas.
Und diese Sachen, da komme ich mit dem SAP-System in Kontakt.
Ansonsten bin ich irgendwie auf der Position der Firma,
die am weitesten weg ist von SAP-System, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Also ich habe noch nie eine Zeit der AVA programmiert,
was halt diese interne Programmiersprache ist von SAP,
die auch so organisch wachsen.
SAP hat eine eigene Programmiersprache?
Die haben sich gedacht, stell dir vor,
wenn Java nicht irgendwie aus C
vorgegangen wäre, so von der Syntax her, sondern aus
SQL.
Genau.
Also es gibt so ganze Telefonbücher,
wo nur die Keywords drin stehen von dieser
Sprache. Diese Sprache hat
irgendwie 600 Keywords oder so.
Ich muss den mal gerade eben
sagen.
A-B-A-P schreit sich das.
Ach, A-B-A-B.
Sicher auch ein Akronym, aber ich weiß nicht für was.
Das ist bestimmt kein gutes Akronym.
Der Grund ist halt, dass so ein SAP-System
im Kern halt so eine Datenbank
drin hat, die halt SQL kann und dann haben sie halt
quasi alles darin reingebaut.
Also haben halt dann die ganze Programmierfähigkeit da reingelötet.
ABAP steht übrigens für Advanced Business
Application Programming, aber Original
Allgemeiner Berichtsaufbereitungsprozessor.
Warum finde ich hier gerade
American Beauty slash American Psycho?
Okay.
Das stimmt glaube ich auch.
Hier steht aber trotzdem
Object Oriented Structured Imperative
Programming Language ABAP 4.
Das ist halt immer so, mit diesen alten Programmiersprachen
die immer noch eingesetzt werden, die saugen einfach alle Paradigmen
auf, also so wie es halt auch die 2011er
Version von Kobol gibt, gibt es halt auch
die 2019er Version von ABAP.
Das ist ein
schlecht gekennzeichneter
Disambiguation-Link auf ein
Fallout Boy-Album aus dem Jahr 2000,
sagen wir was.
Gibt es hier
kurz eine Wigipieler-Seite?
Oder steht die Sprache für
sowas wie All Blobs are Precious?
oder so.
Wunderschön.
Every blob is sacred.
Oh, oh ja.
Oh, hier kommt die
Multi-Python-Referenz.
All binaries are broken.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe ja auch der...
Aber das machst du halt nicht, ne?
Also du arbeitest nicht an ABAP oder mit ABAP?
Also der Mensch, der mir gegenüber saß damals,
als ich Physik-Diploma mitgeschrieben habe,
da saß mir in dem Büro ein Doktorand gegenüber
und der hat halt auch irgendwann dann kurz nach mir
dann, nachdem ich fertig war, dann seine Doktorarbeit
auch fertig gemacht und hat sich dann auch in der
Freien Wirtschaft umgeguckt und ist dann bei derselben Firma wie ich
untergekommen damals, zuerst bei der Bautzen
IT Group, wo ich dann
zweieinhalb Jahre war, bevor ich dann zur SAP gekommen bin.
Und
der hat dann halt ABA-Programmierung gemacht.
Also das ist halt dann so ein SAP-Systemhaus
quasi, die halt wie SAP-Systeme verkaufen
und dann halt so Extensions dafür entwickeln, was
der Kunde halt gerne haben will.
Und der musste halt ABA programmieren und
beziehungsweise, nee, er musste nicht
ABA programmieren, er hat Java programmiert am Ende, aber
ging halt so auf diese Schulungen,
die alle Mitarbeiter am Anfang kriegen, wo sie ABAP lernen.
Und da habe ich dann irgendwie so nach
zwei Wochen ihn so getroffen, so gefragt,
wie ist es denn so? Und da meinte er so,
der hatte halt C++ vorher immer gemacht,
als er halt wissenschaftliches
Rechnen da so gemacht hat
für seine Doktorarbeit. Und der meinte halt so,
ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich das mal sage, aber ich
freue mich so drauf, wenn ich endlich Java programmieren kann.
Ach du Scheiße.
Und da wusste ich alles, was ich wissen muss über ABAP.
Das war auch eine legendäre
Zusammenarbeit, die wir da in diesem Büro hatten.
Also nicht, dass wir an gemeinsamen Themen gearbeitet haben, aber halt
so diesen Dialog, den wir halt so
zwischen Nerds hatten, weil er war
der totale Die-Hard-Emax-Nutzer
und ich bin Die-Hard-Wim-Nutzer.
Und das hat auch total gepasst.
Als ich in dieses Büro neu reingekommen hatte, er gerade
eine Handmanschette wegen Carpathian-Syndrom.
Ui.
Da sieht man den Emax-Nutzer.
Ich will das jetzt nicht verallgemeinern.
Das ist total verallgemeinernbar.
Aber der einzige Unterschied ist eigentlich bloß, dass du bei Emax
möglichst viele Tasten gleichzeitig drückst
und bei Vim möglichst
viele Tasten nacheinander, um
das bei Vimmer nutzen.
Ich glaube, ein Vim-Entwickler kann wesentlich schneller
tippen und ein E-Max-Tipper
hat dafür
irgendwie dem Wachsen
im Laufe seines Lebens noch drei extra Finger.
Der E-Max-Wieser kann auch
mit einem Vorhandschlag auf die Tastatur
alles machen, was er möchte.
Fight me.
Don't add me.
Habt ihr eine Kommentarsektion? Nein.
Oder? Nee.
Wir haben einen Chat und
wir haben Twitter. Genau, schreibt uns
im Namen. Dann kleben wir einfach noch irgendwie so ein Strandbild
dazu und laden das hier als Video bei YouTube hoch
und dann gucken wir, was da in den Kommentaren kommt. Also bei der Firma,
bei der ich jetzt arbeite, bin ich auch von einem Freund
angeworben worden, der daher
E-Maxer ist und mit dem habe ich mir auch schon
den einen oder anderen,
der Jupp, der hier auch schon zweimal zu Gast war.
Ah, Jupp ist der E-Max-User.
Ich habe ihn geoutet.
Und kannst du darüber reden, was du
bei SAP machst du? Genau, ich kann sehr viel
darüber reden, weil tatsächlich so gut wie alles, was ich mache,
Open Source ist. Nice, cool.
Und github.com slash SAPCC.
Du bleibst im
CC-Bereich. Ob CCC
oder SAP-CC? Nee, CC heißt in dem Fall
Converged Cloud.
Das ist tatsächlich so ein relativ
prominenter Markenname, der so innerhalb der SAP
verwendet wird, der tatsächlich von meinem
direkten Chef, beziehungsweise jetzt nicht mehr
direkten Chef, aber der Typ, der
zwei Ebenen über mir sitzt, erfunden wurde,
so quasi ganz schnell noch auf eine Folie gekritzelt wurde
so verfangen hat, wie das halt immer
so ist, weil
quasi es hat ja so
irgendwann vor 15 Jahren oder so hat es so richtig
angefangen mit Virtualisierung, als dann
so Vm-Wer aufkam und dann
auch irgendwie Xen und KVM und
hast du nicht gesehen. Und
das wurde natürlich auch bei der SAP eingesetzt,
weil das die offensichtlichen
Vorteile hat, die wir jetzt nicht
normal alle aufzählen müssen. Und
es hat sich dann halt irgendwann rausgestellt, dass
es dann halt plötzlich so 20 verschiedene
Virtualisierungstecks gab.
Also es gab halt so jede Abteilung hat halt quasi ihr eigenes Hardware-Kontingent halt gehabt, wie das halt so historisch gewachsen war und hat dann deswegen auch ihren eigenen Virtualisierungs-Stack irgendwie gehabt.
Und dann hat halt das eine Team irgendwie...
Und da musste SAP seinen eigenen auch noch dazu haben quasi.
Ja, und es wurde dann halt festgestellt, dass das natürlich irgendwie keine besonders kluge Situation ist, wenn man irgendwie Geld sparen will, wenn man irgendwie 23 Tech-Stacks unterstützen muss.
Ich glaube, es waren wirklich 23 Mal einen bestimmten Punkt, mittlerweile sind es weniger.
Und es wurde dann halt gesagt, wir müssen jetzt auf irgendwas standardisieren.
Und dann ist das halt dieses Converged Cloud Programm da ins Leben gerufen worden.
Und das ist was, wo mein Team so die wesentlichen Entwickler sind.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie unser Team gerade heißt, weil das ändert sich irgendwie andauernd.
Das ist übrigens XKCD 927 Situation.
There are 14 competing standards.
Ja, das war natürlich initial auch so, weil natürlich,
wenn du halt den Standard entwickelst,
dann musst du den halt erstmal entwickeln und dann ist er auch irgendwann
tatsächlich einsatzfähig, aber es wird auch besser mittlerweile.
Und was
wir als TechStack
uns ausgewählt haben, ist
im Prinzip OpenStack auf Kubernetes.
Also OpenStack ist
halt, war halt mal so ein
HypeCycle, also der HypeCycle vor Kubernetes
quasi, was Cloud Computing angeht.
OpenStack war mal, das gibt's,
es ist wohl nicht mehr so Lively oder wie.
Das ist, es ist nicht mehr Hype.
Es ist halt. Also ich meine, ich hab ewig nicht mehr davon
gehört. Es wird von einer gewissen Menge von Leuten
produktiv eingesetzt, aber es hat halt kein Hype mehr dahinter.
Jetzt ist momentan Kubernetes die Kuh, die durchs Dorf
getrieben wird.
Das heißt, ihr setzt euch darauf auf?
Da waren wir tatsächlich so Early Adopter und das hat auch zu einigen
Schmerzen geführt, weil wir stecken auch noch in einer relativ alten Version fest, weil es immer
so ein größeres Projekt ist, wo man Kubernetes upgraden muss.
Das trifft halt immer sehr viele Annahmen.
darüber, wie die Hardware aussieht.
Und wir haben das halt auf Bare Metal laufen,
nicht halt auf Google Cloud Plattformen oder sowas,
weil es läuft ja im eigenen Datacenter.
Und das macht es nicht so trivial zu updaten.
Also halt, weil man halt immer dann,
gerade wenn das halt solche Versionen sind,
wo dann irgendwie das Netzwerk-Setup sich dann wie ändert
von Kubernetes oder wenn das irgendwie neue Interfaces hat,
dann musst du halt deinen ganzen Kram anpassen,
den du dafür gebaut hast,
damit das nicht mit deiner eigenen Netzwerkrate
irgendwie richtig interagiert und so.
Und naja, aber wir haben halt
so eine Kubernetes-Cluster
aufgesetzt in jeder Region,
wo wir unterwegs sind. Also halt irgendwie quasi
einen in Waldorf und einen in
Amsterdam und einen in
US East und einen
in US West und einen in Kanada
und einen in Sydney und so weiter. Das heißt, man kann
SAP Cloud kaufen, so wie man auch
Amazon Cloud kaufen kann quasi?
Nicht so direkt. Also es gibt auch
so ein Offering, wo du das machst. Das ist aber
eins von den anderen, was jetzt schrittweise mit zu uns
migriert wird. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das jetzt noch neuen Kunden
verkauft wird. Ich stecke halt nicht so in unserer Produktpalette
drin, da muss ich dann meinen Bekannten fragen, der als
SAP-Consultant arbeitet, der rieß sowas.
Der arbeitet
zwar nicht bei SAP, aber kennt unsere Produktpalette
besser als ich. Ja, das kenne ich auch häufig.
Aber wir sind halt erst mal so eine interne
Cloud. Wir bieten halt den
ganzen Geschäftsbereichen, die halt bei uns
intern sind, quasi diese Kapazität
an und die gehen dann halt los und
bringen dann die Kunden
an und bauen dann halt ihre Systeme dann bei uns auf, wo
sie dann die Kunden dann drauf installieren.
und mit den Kunden interagieren wir in dem Sinne nicht,
wir interagieren halt mit den ganzen anderen Teilen der Firma,
aber da die ja natürlich alle Geld verdienen,
sind die natürlich ultra wichtig
und deswegen muss das natürlich auch mit einer gewissen Quality of Service ablaufen.
Und da laufen dann auch welche HANA-Datenbanken drauf?
Da laufen viel HANA-Datenbanken drauf,
also so ein aktuelles Projekt ist jetzt gerade,
dass wir so große Payloads,
also wie zum Beispiel HANA-Datenbanken,
nicht nur auf Bare Metal anbieten,
sondern auch als VMs,
was tatsächlich nicht so trivial ist,
wenn du halt so eine VM hast,
die irgendwie drei oder sechs Terabyte RAM hat.
Das macht dann interessante Schwierigkeiten,
erstmal so, was Placement angeht,
weil du brauchst erstmal hinreichend große Hypervisors,
damit dann irgendwie auch nicht einfach nur so eine
vor allem drauf ist und das Ding ist voll.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist denn da die Größe
von der Hostmaschine?
Ja, genau, Größe halt.
In der konkreten Hardware-Zusammenstellung
stecke ich nicht so drin, aber
was wohl auch ein Problem ist bei diesen Big VMs,
ist, dass die wohl signifikant lange brauchen,
migrieren und das willst du ja in so einem
Hypervisor-Szenario machen können, dass du
so VMs auch mal live wegmigrierst, wenn der Hypervisor
irgendwie Probleme hat.
Oder wenn du zum Beispiel so eine Modellabwegung haben willst.
Live wegmigrieren mit 6 Terabyte RAM?
Ja genau, das ist halt ein Problem und
daran knabbern unsere
VM-Ber-Experten zur Zeit auch so ein bisschen.
Das sind ja auch keine Datenmengen, die du irgendwo sind.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Aber ich meine, bei Datenbanken
hast du es ja häufig so,
dass du die eh irgendwie
redundant betreibst, dass du dann quasi
zweimal dasselbe System
identisch möglichst
nebeneinander laufen lässt, oder?
Dementsprechend kann es auch wahrscheinlich so eine Migration von so einer...
Das macht dir halt eine TCU
kaputt, weil so eine 6-Therabyte-Kiste,
die kostet halt schon signifikant Geld.
Und, also egal, ob es jetzt
eine VM ist oder eine Bare-Metal-Kiste,
und wenn du dann halt zwei von den Dingern betreiben musst,
Total Cost of Ownership,
dann ist das halt doppelt so teuer.
Und wenn halt
deiner Infrastruktur
Bill ausmacht.
Achso, aber die Leute stellen sich trotzdem lieber eine
fette VM hin, als viele
kleinere VMs? Ja, und halt Backup halt.
Okay, abgefahren.
Also es ist halt immer noch besser, wenn du halt den
Storage nur doppelt haben musst, beziehungsweise halt Snapshot
ist, anstatt dass du wirklich zwei VMs
stehen hast, wenn halt so eine VM irgendwie
x-tausend Euro im Monat kostet.
Und wenn das halt 20% von dem Geld
ist, was du dem Kunden irgendwie am Ende auf die Rechnung
schreibst, dann macht halt so eine doppelte
Infrastrukturrechnung
halt schon mal einen großen Teil deiner
aus. Sicherlich.
In diesem
Compute-Thema oder so bin ich gar nicht selber unterwegs,
sondern ich bin so in zwei Themenfeldern unterwegs.
Das eine ist Object Storage, also
das nennt sich als Produkt OpenStack Swift
und ist sowas wie AWS S3.
Things called Swift.
Genau, Things called Swift. Das hatten wir bereits
in unserer allerersten Folge. Echt?
Gruß an Philipp gerade,
der mich vorgestern angeschrieben hat,
dass er jetzt endlich angefangen hat, unseren Podcast mal zu hören
und mich mittendrin
irgendwie auf irgendwelche Sachen angeschrieben hat,
die wir irgendwann in dieser ersten, allerersten
nullten Podcast-Folge gesagt haben
und ich so, du weißt genau, dass ich mich
nicht mehr daran erinnere, was ich vor zwei Jahren mal
in deinem Mikrofon gesprochen habe. Ich habe auch überlegt, als ich angefangen
habe, vorhin den Podcast hören, ob ich jetzt so Notizen machen muss
und dann einfach so eine Sendung mache, wo ich einfach
meine ganzen Notizen konfrontiere.
Ja, du musst uns halt vorher sagen,
was wir gesagt haben, damit wir das noch wissen.
Das war meine Meinung.
Ich habe tatsächlich angefangen, unsere nullte Folge noch mal
zu hören, um überhaupt zu wissen, wovon er redet und was er
mir da gerade vorwirft, was wir da gesagt haben.
Ich kann ja auch alles behaupten,
was wir gesagt haben. Das ist ja so weit her,
dass es gefühlt vorm Stimmbruch, ne?
Tatsächlich, wir haben
noch andere Mikrofone benutzt.
Oh ja, Mikrofone, genau.
Das eine habe ich schon auf die nächsten Mikrofone, ehrlich gesagt.
Und ja,
so Object Storage mache ich
da als Thema und da hängen halt noch so ein paar andere
Themen dran, die dann irgendwie noch so dazukommen.
Zum Beispiel haben wir so Replikationen,
dass wir Betriebssystem-Repos
zu uns rein replizieren, damit dann nicht
jeder Kunde nochmal ins Internet raus telefonieren muss,
um sein Ubuntu-Pakete zu holen.
Achso, aber Object Storage ist quasi so das
FDP des reichen Mannes quasi, oder?
Ja, Object Storage
ist halt quasi so wie Dropbox.
Du hast halt so einen Dienst, wo du halt Dateien
reinkippst und dann kümmern die sich halt darum, dass das
repliziert ist und gebackupt ist und so weiter.
Und du holst es dann halt irgendwann da wieder raus.
Kannst da noch Metadaten rankleben.
Und ja, das ist halt das im Wesentlichen.
Es ist nicht so ganz dasselbe wie ein Filesystem.
Also es gibt dann auch so NFS-Proxy-Treiber
für Swift oder sowas, aber das ist
nicht so geil. Also eigentlich sollte man
schon, weil NFS macht ja schon
gewisse starke Annahmen darüber, wie Filesysteme funktionieren
und das ist halt da nicht gegeben.
Zum Beispiel ist das eventually
consistent, also die Liste von allen
Dateien, die es gibt, ist halt so eine Datenbank, die
halt so lazily geupdatet
wird und wenn halt gerade viel Dampf ist auf
deinem Container, wenn da halt jetzt 100.000 Wege hochgeladen
werden, dann kann es halt einfach sein, dass es eine gewisse Zeit
dauert, bis es immer beim Listing auftritt und wir geben
auch keine Garantien raus, wie lange das dauert.
Das ist am Anfang öfter mal passiert, dass Kunden
gefragt haben, wie viele Sekunden dauert es denn halt,
bis es jetzt geupdatet ist? Und dann schreiben wir so zurück,
es dauert so lange, bis es geupdatet ist.
Das ist eine gute Aussage.
Das hat halt so eine Queue, und wenn du halt viel Dampf machst
auf dem Ding, dann ist die Queue halt lang.
Und wenn wir dann noch irgendwie replizieren,
weil wir gerade die Topologie vom Cluster ändern,
neue Kisten aufnehmen oder eine kaputte
Platte irgendwie ersetzen oder sowas, dann dauert das halt
im Zweifelsfall länger. Und du hast gerade gesagt,
ihr migriert auch
Repositories von Linux-Distributionen rein?
Ja. Das heißt...
Naja, weil du hast ja quasi 20.000 Ubuntu-VMs rumzustehen oder was auch immer das dann ist.
Und dann willst du natürlich nicht, dass die alle irgendwie daraus telefonieren, um dann 20.000 Mal G-Lip-C runterzuladen.
Macht ihr das auch für Package-Manager von hier irgendwelchen Programmiersprachen, die ihr intern verwendet?
Das ist bis jetzt noch nicht an uns angetragen worden, aber prinzipiell würde nichts dagegen sprechen, wenn es halt eine Anforderung ist vom Kunden.
Der Kunde kann sowas halt prinzipiell auch selber bauen in seinen eigenen Containern.
Achso, ihr habt sowas nicht, weil du hast vorhin was gesagt, du machst Go auf Arbeit, ne?
Das ist auch dieses
Replizieren von Repos machen wir mit
Swift HTTP Import, was
ein Go-Programm ist,
wo quasi unsere gesamte Expertise
als Swift Admins drin steckt,
wie man richtig Swift repliziert.
Es gibt auch so ein anderes Tool,
was sowas ähnliches macht, das nennt sich
R-Clone. Das ist so wie
R-Sync, aber kann halt quasi alle
Cloud-Backends immer.
Da kannst du halt quasi
von Dropbox zu Swift oder
von FTP zu SFTP
oder was hin und her sinken.
Und das Problem
ist halt, dass das halt generisch ist und deswegen
kann es halt nicht
so Spezialfeatures von Swift oder sowas
richtig verstehen und umsetzen
und sowas.
Ich kann halt den gemeinsamen Nenner von all
diesen Sachen nennen. Ja und wir haben halt Swift HTTP
Import, das ist halt spezifischer
darauf ausgelegt,
dass es auf GitHub unter diese SAP-CC-Organisation
zu finden. Es gibt etwas, das Wasabi heißt.
Wir hatten heute
Teamfrühstück, da hat er unsere chinesische Kollegin
Sushi mitgebracht und die hatte
das gute Wasabi dabei.
Das Schadenbrettende. Das, was nicht
irgendwie nochmal verdünnt ist?
Ich habe ein bisschen geweint heute.
Aber cool,
stimmt das eigentlich, dass, das ist jetzt eine
etwas kontroverse Frage, aber stimmt das eigentlich, dass
SAP HANA
von der NSA eingesetzt wird?
Habe ich keinen
Einblick. Hast du keine Ahnung? Ich bin nicht
im Kundengeschäft tätig. Achso, das war
nämlich was, was ich mal so am Rande gehört habe.
kann bei
Netzpolitico auch gewesen sein
oder sowas, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt.
Ich sage jetzt mal nichts dazu,
weil ich könnte jetzt natürlich meine Privatmännern
dazu vertreten oder
könnte jetzt irgendwie ganz pragmatisch darüber reden,
wie das auch so manchmal meine Art ist, aber nee.
Das ist so der Grund, warum ich...
Also ich meine, ich kann es prinzipiell vorstellen,
so wie ich mal vorstellen kann, dass die NSA auch irgendwie
Postgres einsetzt, aber...
Sicherlich. Bei irgendwelchen Tech-Sacks müssen die auch benutzen.
Im Zweifelsfall hacken die sich einfach bei uns rein und holen sich den Source-Code selber.
Und nehmen sich aus der Zappedia noch die Installationsanleitung mit.
Funfact, Zappedia gibt es wirklich.
Das ist so ein Wiki, wo nur Akronyme-Expansionen drin stehen.
Nice, wichtig bei solchen Filmen.
Das ist quasi das Gegenteil von Akronymisierbar.
Ja, genau. Die haben irgendwie, glaube ich, über 2000 Einträge.
Ja, das war bei Apple auch sehr interessant.
Du musst auch die ersten Wochen, Monate nur mit beschäftigt damit rauszusuchen.
Was sind denn die ganzen Abkürzungen eigentlich?
ist das hier die
Urheilungste? Nee, das ist nicht öffentlich.
Ach, schade aber auch. Das ist nur im Intranet.
Ich wollte es gerade in die
Show Notes gießen.
Also es gibt
öffentlich auch noch dieses
SAP Community Network oder so, aber da bin ich halt auch nicht
drin, weil das ist halt quasi so, wo sich halt diese
ganzen SAP-Consultants rumtreiben, die irgendwie ABBA
programmieren und irgendwie SAP-Systeme installieren.
Damit möchte ich nichts
zu tun haben, soweit es irgendwie geht.
Naja, und das
zweite Thema, wo ich dann unterwegs bin, ist Resource Management.
weil das kam dann halt auch so auf
es gibt bei OpenStack halt so
die Mate kommt hier
in Form von Kundensäure wieder zurück
dann fang einfach den Satz nochmal an
und dann mache ich hier so ein Edit Point
das zweite was ich hier
mache ist bei Resource Management
und das Problem da ist
dass OpenStack zwar so ein Konzept von Quotas hat
aber das ist halt hauptsächlich sowas was halt
der Kunde selber sich setzt damit irgendwie
seinen Skript nicht irgendwie durchdreht und jetzt plötzlich
10.000 VMs startet. Also das heißt der Kunde kann sich schon
seine eigene Quota setzen.
Ja, genau, so ist das halt standardmäßig konfiguriert und das wollten wir halt nicht,
weil wir möchten darüber Kapazitätsmanagement und Planung und sowas machen
und das soll halt quasi von oben verordnet werden, das Quota.
Und deswegen habe ich da so einen Dienst gebaut, der dann Quota hierarchisch durch die Domänen und Projekte dann durchreicht
und das nennt sich Limes.
Ist das nicht eher etwas, was trennt?
Ja, das ist das Quota, was die Römer auf die Germanen gesetzt haben.
Bis hierhin könnt ihr euch ja weiter...
So viele Germanen kommen rein und das raser.
Es hat so die erste Zeit lang,
so die ersten sechs Monate, haben alle immer nur Limes
ausgesprochen. Und jetzt mittlerweile
habe ich sie aber hinreichend trainiert, dass das Limes heißt.
Das ist ein hartes Jahr.
Das erinnert mich an etwas, was ich auf Arbeit mache, weil wir manchmal,
wir sprechen ja sehr, wir sprechen den ganzen Tag Englisch,
aber nur unter Deutschen. Und dann sind so ein paar
Aussprachefehler
drin, sowas wie Test.
Prometheus?
Prometheus gibt es ja auch auf Deutsch,
aber sowas wie Test-Suit.
Generell das Wort
Sweet und Suit ist
sehr, sehr schwierig für deutsche
Arigüe. Genau. Oder
Legacy.
Und ich habe bei manchen, oder Assearchen.
Ich finde es immer ganz schlimm, wenn Leute Cocoa statt Coco
sagen. Und genau. Und ich habe
dann vor kurzem einfach angefangen zu sagen,
wenn jemand TestSuite
gesagt hat, habe ich gesagt, Sweet.
Und jetzt war es auch wie,
nachdem ich das ein, zwei Wochen durchgezogen habe, kam es tatsächlich
dazu, dass im Stand-Up
jemand gesagt hat, ja, wir müssen da noch was
in der TestSuite anpassen.
hat sich so selber schnell angefangen
an und dann haben alle so
angefangen zu schmutzeln und wieder rüber zu gucken,
weil sie jetzt alle anfangen, sich selbst zu korrigieren.
Stark. Es hat gefruchtet.
Konditionierung funktioniert, ja.
Und in dem
Thema bin ich jetzt, da habe ich jetzt auch
dieses Jahr wieder einen neuen Service gebaut,
weil es kam dann noch so die Anforderung dazu,
dass Dinge sich automatisch
skalieren sollen, also dass so ein,
wenn du quasi zum Beispiel so ein NFS-Share hast, dass der
irgendwie je nach
Utilization automatisch kleiner oder größer werden soll
und das habe ich dann
in demselben Namenschema quasi weitergeführt.
Der Dienst heißt Castellum.
Du hast ja hinter den Linus
einen Kilometer weiter, hast du dann solche
Castelle, wo dann die Reinforcements kommen.
Und das ist dann die Verstärkung, wenn das dann
automatisch was kann. Ich brauche mal ein kleines Latinum.
Ich liebe dein Name-Scheme.
Ich muss mal einen Kollegen von mir einladen,
der hat an einem Tool gearbeitet. Das heißt,
das ist momentan noch intern,
aber es heißt
nicht Montenegro, sondern
wo ist dieses eine Formel 1-Rennen?
Monaco?
Der hat an einem Tool gearbeitet, das heißt Monaco
und das ist so ein Tool, mit dem man
Grafana-Boards, wegen Graf
von Monaco
erzeugt und da heißen
Credentials, heißen da Passports
und der hat dieses
Also manchmal ist es ein bisschen anstrengend,
wenn die so nämlich wirklich tief in den Projekt
Der hat wirklich für alles Begriffe aus diesem Umfeld.
Da ist das nämlich schon eher so ein DSL an sich.
Das war ein bisschen krass.
Bei Castellum gibt es,
das ist halt auch so ein System aus mehreren Komponenten,
und da gibt es zurzeit den Observer,
der dann quasi auf dem Turm steht und beobachtet,
was die Assets alle so machen.
Da gibt es doch eigentlich ein lateinisches Wort für,
was du hättest verwenden können, oder?
Ja, ich wollte es nicht ganz unverständlich machen,
das müssen ja auch irgendwie noch Leute supporten.
Und dann den Bürger, der dann was macht,
und ich habe jetzt noch die Idee für eine weitere Komponente,
die man dann auch rausziehen könnte, um sie zu parallelisieren.
Das steht jetzt in meinem
Ticket drin, dass das wahrscheinlich dann Scout heißt.
Da würde ich aber schon die
ordentlichen römischen passenden Begriffe
für die Peel. Ja, wie gesagt, das müssen
ja noch Leute verstehen können, warum das so heißt und was
das macht und so. Also da kannst du
Projektnamen quasi sind, auch wenn es relativ kleine, kompakte
Komponenten sind, dann finde ich das okay.
Oberatus. Ah, das ist der Herr Beobachter.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin auch jetzt gerade dabei, einen neuen Service zu
bauen. Also es wurde
offenbar identifiziert, dass ich gut darin bin,
neue Services auszudrucken,
so in Masse und
jetzt bin ich gerade dabei, einen Docker-Registry-
als-a-Service zu machen.
Also Docker-Registry selber
ist schon so eine Standard-Komponente, die kann man sich halt
hinstellen, die hat allerdings selber noch keine
auf, da muss man auch so einen OAuth-Provider
daneben stellen und
es kann auch selber noch nicht so richtig Multitenancy,
also du könntest dann halt so einen Multitenancy-fähigen
OAuth-Provider haben, damit halt mehrere
Leute sich separat authentifizieren können
und dann wie getrennt voneinander sein können
und dann hast du aber trotzdem noch das Problem, dass diese
Registry nur einen Speicher-Backend hat.
Und Swift ist zum Beispiel
ein mögliches Speicher-Backend, aber du kannst dann halt nur
in einen Swift-Container Daten reinkippen und der
wird dann halt, wenn du halt 100 Kunden
draufschickst, im Zweifelsfall gigantisch.
Und die kommen sich dann halt auch
dadurch in die Quere, weil so ein Swift-Container
wird halt auch irgendwann langsam, wenn dann halt diese Objektlistings
halt einfach irgendwie eine Million Objekte lang sind oder so.
Und deswegen werden die schon
irgendwie trennen können. Und da bin ich jetzt gerade dabei,
ein Docker-Registry-as-a-Service
zu bauen, der
die Kunden komplett isoliert, indem er
kunden eine neue registry startet und das soll dann das ist jetzt zur zeit noch
das ist nur einfach so ein lokaler prozess ist es wird dann so sein dass das
dann auch in kubernetes abgebildet wird dass dann jeder kunde quasi seinen
eigenen pot kriegt und das wird dann halt durch geproxied zu den entsprechenden
pots die anfragen die der kunde dann da schickt und da bin ich jetzt da gerade
dran das heißt keppel und das ist das benannt das ist nach einem britischen
Flottengeneral benannt.
Der hat...
Wir haben quasi geguckt,
bei Docker und sowas bietet sich immer so diese
Nautik-Schiene an als
Naming-Scheme. Und es gibt
in Shanghai einen Teilhafen,
der heißt halt Keppelhafen oder Keppelport.
In dem Fall, weil dieser
General Keppel war da berühmt
geworden, dadurch, dass er da wie Piratenschiffe versenkt hat.
Und da die Schiffsrouten
freigemacht hat.
Nicht schlecht. Wir haben für sowas, glaube ich,
Artifactory auch als Docker-Registering.
bei uns im Laufen.
Du, ich glaube, wir nähern uns langsam der 2-Stunden-Marke,
wenn ich richtig auf die Uhr schaue.
Genau, ich schaue gerade auf die Uhr und ich sehe,
dass wir uns der 2-Stunden-Marke zuwenden.
Und deswegen würde ich fast gerne mal umschwenken
auf ein oder zwei der anderen Themen,
die wir noch auf der Liste haben.
Was haben wir noch auf der Liste?
Wir haben zum Beispiel, dass du in Basel warst
und da auf einem Open Data Meetup geredet hast.
Stimmt, der Johannes und ich,
stimmt, Johannes war ja auch schon mal im Podcast.
Das war die Folge, wo wir auf den Daten schon waren,
wo er ja über ADA gesprochen hat.
Wir haben ja seit
vor ein paar Jahren mal so ein Projekt mit dem tollen
Namen ParkenDD gestartet, um
einfach mal irgendwas mit Open Data zu machen,
obwohl wir beide sehr begeisterte Nicht-Autofahrer
sind und dieses Projekt seitdem
nicht wirklich... Und ihr dachtet euch, die Autofahrer in Dresden, die muss man
unbedingt unterstützen? Ja, was heißt
unterstützen? Vielleicht hilft das Projekt ja sogar, dass die Leute
nicht so sehr oben herfahren. Es ist so ein Projekt, wo man
ich glaube, da habe ich bestimmt schon mal angesprochen,
Parkplatzdaten in der App anzeigt,
wie wir sammeln die generell und nicht nur für Dresden, sondern auch für andere
Städte und machen halt so ein bisschen offene
daraus, weil wir die halt bereitstellen. Jeder kann sich
die Dumps runterladen und auch alte
Daten anschauen. Und
wir haben vor fünf Jahren
oder so mal ins Leben gerufen und
seitdem lebt das ein bisschen vor sich hin mit sehr wenig Maintenance
Aufwand. Wir stecken auch nicht
wirklich viel Arbeit rein. Und wir wurden jetzt
vor kurzem, beziehungsweise vor kurzem hat die Stadt Basel
sich da selbst reingepro-requestet,
was ich sehr, sehr toll fand.
Also man muss dazu sagen, es hatte
sich am Anfang auf Dresden beschränkt
und dann habt ihr ja selber ein paar Städte hinzugefügt,
einfach aus Langeweile,
wo ihr es auf Webseiten gefunden habt und
scrapen konntet. Genau, da wo wir Daten sammeln konnten,
haben wir Daten hinzugefügt. Kurz darauf kam
sogar die Stadt Zürich auf uns zu
und hat gesagt, hier ist unser
Open-Data-Portal, wie wäre es denn damit? Ich finde das
großartig. Das war
unser erster Kontakt mit wirklich maschinenlesbaren
Datenquellen dafür.
Wie gesagt, die Stadt Basel
hat sich vor kurzem selbst reingeprogramm
und hat uns jetzt, weil
diese Projekte sehr, sehr toll finden
und da auch wirklich tolle Infrastruktur in Basel
haben, jetzt nicht auf Parkplatzdaten,
sondern generell auf Open Data aus der Verwaltung raus,
haben die gesagt, die machen
hier so ein Open Data Bier, nennt sich das
Meetup, was die da machen, wo es um offene Daten
und viel Bier geht.
Offenes Bier und offene Daten. Exakt.
Haben sie uns eingeladen, da mal
vorbeizukommen und ein kleines Input-Referat zu halten,
was es denn mit dem Projekt auf sich hat
und wie das sich so entwickelt hat. Und da sind wir
letzte Woche nach Basel gefahren.
Das ist echt eine tolle Stadt.
Ich war sehr begeistert. Basel ist hübsch.
Echt hübsch und vor allem, was wir beide unglaublich
fanden, war, dass die an sehr
vielen Kreuzungen zu Zebrastreifen haben.
Manchmal mit Ampeln, manchmal meistens
nicht. Aber dass du halt einfach durch die Stadt
läufst, du latschst an jedem Zebrastreifen darüber, jedes
Auto hält halt instant an.
Und du läufst halt einfach in einer Geschwindigkeit
durch diese Stadt, das wäre hier undenkbar.
Weil hier musst du halt überall stehen bleiben,
aufpassen, dass du nicht überfahren wirst, an der Fußgängerampelle kurz warten
und da läufst du halt einfach weiter und weiter
und weiter und weiter. Das macht mega
Spaß, da Fußgänger zu sein. Das war sehr
unerwartet. Ansonsten wirklich
schicke kleine Stadt und dieses Meetup hat auch sehr viel Spaß
macht da mal so ein bisschen auch die Historie
von dem Projekt, auch wenn es, wie gesagt, nicht so viel
passiert ist, aber das nochmal selbst so
Revue passieren zu lassen und mal zu schauen, was da
eigentlich war und das den Leuten
zu präsentieren
und im Nachhinein auch sehr viel
spannenden Input zu bekommen, was denn generell so
noch Sache ist und was man noch so machen könnte und
was man dann, ja,
es gab sehr viel tollen Input zu, waren auch
unerwartet viele Leute da, ich habe so ehrlich gesagt
mit so 10, 12 Leuten gerechnet, waren 40
dann tatsächlich bei den Daten. Und ihr hattet einen Vortrag
vorbereitet über euer Projekt? Genau, so
10-15 Minuten Ding einfach mal.
Gibt es eine Aufzeichnung davon?
Ne, leider nicht.
Dann müsst ihr den wohl nochmal in Dresden vorführen.
Ja, vielleicht irgendwann mal, wenn wir das Projekt hoffentlich mal...
Eben Abend im Hackerspace.
Genau.
Ist auch nicht so das spannendste Projekt, wie gesagt, aber
vielleicht kriegen wir jetzt mal einen neuen Namen zustande.
Leitenden Talk auf den Datenspuren.
Ihr hattet ja auf Twitter rumgefragt,
wie sollen wir es nennen?
Und es war irgendwas anderes.
Und Marky McParkface war eine der Optionen.
Ja, ich wollte es schon länger mal umbenennen, weil der
Parken DD heißt,
DD für Dresden und der Bezug zu Dresden
ist ja schon lange flöten gegangen.
Und mein Wunsch war eigentlich Lottie, weil ich das
süß fand, wie Parking Lot.
Dann gab es noch Open Parking, was sehr viele Leute
passend fanden, obwohl es ja schon mehrere Projekte gibt.
Expandier doch einfach Parken DD als Parken
dort drüben. Ja, Parken
da und dort hat Johannes schon mal gemeint.
Jetzt ist wohl auch,
andere Leute haben vorgeschlagen, das Parken Data Driven
zu nennen.
Ich finde den Namen trotzdem kräftig.
Ah, Data Driven.
An Driven habe ich gar nicht gedacht, oh Gott.
Deswegen heißt es ja DD, Data Driven, oder?
Ach, wegen Driven meinst du?
Der Driven-Wortwitz ist noch
vorbeigegangen bis eben.
Aber ich habe gerade reingeguckt, bei Twitter hat
leider wirklich Parky-Mac Parkface gewonnen.
Dann müssen wir es halt so nennen.
Dann müssen wir es Parky-Mac Parkface nennen.
Twitter-Polls sind ja auch autoritativ.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn wir es ja nicht so nennen, dann werden wir ja
gededosed, äh, bis zum
Parkendepäden.
Bis zum geht nicht mehr, so müssen wir es ja Parkendepäden
nennen, sonst. Zu Basel, also ich war
mal in Basel, aber nur durchgefahren, aber
das hat mir noch eine Anekdote gebracht, weil da
war ich damals noch von Schwerin gekommen,
also wo ich aufgewachsen war, da waren
wir mal in die Richtung runtergefahren und man kann
ab Hamburg, zumindest konnte man das damals mit dem
IC, bis nach Basel durchfahren, also so neun Stunden
oder so. Kann man theoretisch jetzt auch noch.
Und ich war tatsächlich jetzt
neulich nach der GPN, war ich zu meinen Eltern
gefahren und da war ich von Karlsruhe nach Schwerin im
ICE durchgefahren. Das heißt, ich habe die
GPR schon wieder verpasst. Das war eine sehr
angenehme Fahrt,
obwohl die Klimaanlage wieder ein bisschen übereifrig war,
weil das ist ja öfter so bei der Deutschen Bahn.
Und auf jeden Fall, so der Fahrt war ich halt,
waren halt von Hamburg bis Basel durchgefahren
und dann in Basel irgendwie umgestiegen
und da hatte der Zug
irgendwie zwischenzeitlich auch so eine halbe Stunde Verspätung
aufgesammelt auf dieser Strecke, hatte
dann aber irgendwie völlig wahnwitziger
Weise in diesem letzten
Stück zwischen Karlsruhe und Basel ist alles wieder
aufgeholt und das habe ich mir dann so rationalisiert
dass dem Zug einfach die Einreise verweigert worden wäre,
wenn er nicht pünktlich gewesen wäre.
Genau den Spaß hatten wir eben.
Der Zug hatte anderthalb Stunden Verspätung,
weil die hatten da irgendwelche Störungen in irgendwelchen Stellwerken.
Aber die waren halt schon lange bekannt.
Das war jetzt nichts, was an dem Tag passiert ist.
Und die sind seit Wochen dieselben Störungen.
Und die haben einfach trotzdem da erstmal eine halbe Stunde Verspätung.
Da standen wir noch ein bisschen rum.
Und dann hat der Zug eine Stunde Verspätung.
Also der fährt eigentlich durch Zürich, St. Gallen,
noch irgendwo weiter da unten.
Nicht Zürich, durch Basel, durch St. Gallen,
irgendwo anders, der in der Schweiz noch hin.
weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das schon aussah.
Und das hieß am Anfang schon, dem Zug ist
die Einreise ins SBB-Netz schon längst
untersagt worden, aber
der fährt bis Basel auf jeden Fall noch hin, weil Basel ist
quasi die Endhaltestelle für das deutsche
Netz. Basel-Bad ist der Bahnhof. Genau, Basel-Bad
wäre noch DB, Basel-SBB
ist dann der Schweizer Bahnhof, aber Basel-SBB war wie gesagt
die eigentliche Endhaltestelle für den Zug.
Bis sie dann plötzlich kurz davor gesagt haben, ja,
der Zug hat jetzt anderthalb Stunden Verspätung, es lohnt
gar nicht mehr, bis Basel-SBB zu fahren, wir hören in Freiburg
einfach auf mit dem Zug. Ja, und
wir haben ein Dicke bis nach Basel, wie kommen
jetzt hin, dann müsst ihr jetzt halt schauen.
Das hatte ich jetzt einmal, als ich Richtung Leipzig
gefahren habe mit diesem EC2
und dann standen wir halt am Hauptbahnhof
auf dem Gleis und warteten auf, dass dieser Zug
einfährt und dann kam so die Ansage,
ne, nehmen sie mal bitte die S-Bahn, der Zug fährt Leute von Dresden-Neustadt.
Weil der war halt einfach von Leipzig
schon in der vorigen Tour
so verspätet, dass sie ihn einfach in Neustadt
schon enden lassen, damit sie irgendwie nochmal 10 Minuten wieder rausholen.
Diese DB.
Es hat funktioniert, weil der war halt auch so viel
verspätet, dass das irgendwie noch funktioniert hat alles,
aber schon echt faszinierend.
Ich finde es geil, dass die halt einfach dann sagen,
es lohnt nicht mehr bis zum Ende zu fahren.
Für euch vielleicht nicht.
Ich war aber neulich positiv überrascht.
Ich war an dem Tag unterwegs von Stuttgart nach Dresden,
wo gerade dieser Schubser war in Frankfurt,
der da die Leute aufs Gleis geschubst hat mit Todesfolge.
Krass, habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Der Mutter und Kind aufs Gleis geschubst hat
und nur die Mutter konnte sich retten oder so.
Das Kind halt nicht.
Und dann war halt quasi der Frankfurter Bahnhof halt abgesperrt relativ lang, was natürlich zu dem vorhersagbaren Verkehrschaos führt, weil das ja doch irgendwie ein Knotenpunkt ist, so ein bisschen.
Und ich wollte da den Tag gerade von Stuttgart nach Dresden und ich war halt eigentlich gebucht auf eine Strecke, wo mein ICE von Stuttgart bis Leipzig durchfährt, also auch über Frankfurt.
Und da hätte ich nur noch in Leipzig dann halt in den ICE nach Dresden umsteigen müssen.
Das ist eigentlich eine coole Verbindung und so weiter.
Und, naja, ich kam halt von einem Standort ein bisschen außerhalb von Stuttgart,
war dann noch mit der S-Bahn reingefahren und ich war in weiser Voraussicht nicht so,
wie dass die mir die App vorgeschlagen hat, irgendwie so,
hier kannst du drei Minuten vor der Angst fahren und dann ganz schnell in den Stuttgart Hauptbahnhof umsteigen.
Genau.
Weil ja auch Stuttgart Hauptbahnhof gerade total übersichtlich ist.
Stuttgart ist kein Bahnhof.
Stuttgart ist ja eine Haltestelle.
Ja, genau.
Eine Baustelle mit Gleisen.
Ich finde das großartig.
Und ich, so ein weißer
Voraussicht, fahre mal eine halbe Stunde früher,
komme so auf diesem Bahnhof,
auf diesem Gleis am Stuttgarter Bahnhof an, da steht
so gleich ihr Zugfeld aus.
Super.
Nach nur kurzer Suche von einer Viertelstunde finde ich ein Reisezentrum.
Irgendwo zwischen den ganzen Baustellen.
Und ja, so hier,
also mein Zugfeld hört nicht, was ist denn
hier los? Und dann, der Mitarbeiter
war aber auf Zack, der hat dann halt in seinem
System rumgesucht und meint dann so,
ich habe hier eine Verbindung für Sie, da können Sie
über Nürnberg fahren. In Nürnberg
dann den ICE auf dieser neuen
super Schnellfahrstrecke hier zwischen Berlin und München,
der bringt sie nach Erfurt
und dort können sie ihren
ursprünglichen ICE einholen.
Denn der fährt, das war halt quasi auch
so eine Störung am Zug und deswegen hatte der den Tag
davor in Frankfurt geendet und sollte halt von
Frankfurt anfangen. Und mit dem
Plan halt hätte ich den einholen können. Dann
gibt er mir so diesen ausgedruckten Fahrplan. Ich so, hier steht
aber, dass der Zug um 10.09 fällt. Da haben sie aber schon 10.30 Uhr.
Nee, die erste Dreiviertelstunde verspätet.
Aha, cool.
Und das hat auch tatsächlich geklappt.
Also ich war wirklich zu der geplanten Zeit dann in Erfurt.
Allerdings war dann halt dieses Unglück passiert,
wodurch dieser Zug nicht losfahren konnte in Frankfurt
und hat da trotzdem gefehlt.
Aber da konnte nun die Deutsche Bahn wirklich nichts für.
Und so gut, am Ende war ich halt doch wieder eine Stunde später da,
weil ich halt einfach dann den Zug eine Stunde später genommen habe.
Aber das war schon eine sehr positive Leistung.
Da war ich mit der Beratung durchaus zufrieden an dem Moment.
Also man muss ja auch mal sagen, die Deutsche Bahn macht zwar viel Scheiße,
aber manchmal kriegen sie es auch ganz gut hin,
auch wenn sie in dem Fall jetzt trotzdem mehr 25 Prozent zurückzahlen mussten.
Aber erst ab 60 Minuten, bei 59 gibt es noch nicht, das hört ihr auch schon.
Ja, ja, es war aber, ich glaube, der Zug war dann auch irgendwie fünf Minuten später wieder da und dadurch passt es dann.
Apropos Beratung, das war auch schön am Schweizer Bahnhof, als wir zurückgefahren sind,
waren wir ein bisschen frühzeitig aus dem Hotel los sind und zum Bahnhof gelaufen sind dort.
Ein bisschen zu früh am Bahnhof, eine halbe Stunde bevor der Zug abfuhr
und der Zug stand noch nicht am Gleis dran, am Monitor,
Wir waren uns nicht ganz sicher, ab welchem Gleis der fährt.
Das stand in der App eben auch nicht drin.
Und wir waren halt generell so klug, dass wir nicht gemerkt haben,
dass Schweiz ja nicht EU-Ausland ist.
Wir hatten auch kein mobiles Internet dort.
Und sind halt zum Schalter, um zu fragen, wo der Zug abfährt.
Das weiß ich doch nicht.
Steht hier noch nicht auf dem Display.
Ja, gut, dann...
Wann war denn das?
Jetzt bei eurem letzten Trip?
Ich dachte, das Roaming funktioniert auch in der Schweiz.
Nicht, wenn du nur EU-Ausland hast.
Ich habe nur Roaming im EU-Ausland.
Schweiz ist kein EU-Ausland.
Da muss ich nochmal gucken, weil ich bin jetzt
ab nächster Woche in Norwegen.
Das ist EU-Ausland, oder?
Nee.
Genau, deswegen, Kranplätze müssen
verdichtet werden.
Oder waren das die Finnen?
Kranplätze müssen verdichtet werden, deswegen sind die auch nicht in der EU.
Wegen der Norweger sieht
die skandinavische Halbinsel
auf den Euromünzen aus
wie ein Penis, weil nämlich
Norwegen oben nicht dabei ist.
Cool.
Wollen wir mal ein bisschen weiter hier.
Gut, der letzte Satz wird aus dem Protokoll gestrichen.
Quatsch.
Cool, aber wir haben ja noch ein bisschen andere Themen
hier auf unserer Liste.
Also wir hatten ja gerade, dass der Kilian
in der Schweiz war und dass die Schweiz so ein wunderschönes
Land ist.
Wollen wir
auf unsere GitHub-Stars eingehen?
Würde ich mal dazu raten.
Wir sind bei zwei Stunden.
Ja, nee, dann gehen wir mal zu den GitHub-Stars.
Hast du irgendwas gefunden, Stefan?
Ich habe hier einmal
Exterminate.
Das ist eine
Python-Library, die man unbedingt in jeden
Production-Code einsetzen muss, die man
hat. Das kann man sich
sehr schön in den Lieden dort angucken.
Was man so alles damit machen kann,
da kann man so ein bisschen alternative Interpretationen
von Mathematik und
Logik
und so durchsetzen.
Was sind denn alternative Interpretationen?
Ich würde sagen, das bringt jetzt auch nichts,
das hier irgendwie groß auszuwalzen.
Da haben wir den Link dazu in den Shownotes und guckt euch das an.
Hier steht auch so die ganz kleine...
Float 1,5 plus Float 0,5
ist gleich 0,99487447.
Was?
Ist doch falsch.
Sehe ich nichts Falsches dabei.
Let's think rationally yes, pun intended.
Große Alter.
Okay, also Einstein once said,
I don't know what World War 3 will be fought with,
but World War 4 will be fought with
Import Exterminate.
Das ist auch eine Karte aus Karls Against Humanity.
Ja. Oh Mann.
Okay, also wenn man
Mathe falsch rechnen möchte, dann kann man sich diese
Python-Library reinziehen. Das heißt falsch, anders.
Ist ja nicht falsch. Achso, das sind alternative
Fakten.
Alternative Floats.
Was mich da eigentlich
nur noch mehr davon überzeugt, Python nicht produktiv
einzusetzen. Python ist eine tolle Sprache.
Also das war ja auch
in meinem ersten
Team, wo ich bei SAP damals war,
haben wir eine Perl-Applikation
maintained. Und da habe ich dann halt
Pearl gelernt. Also quasi, ich bin dann so quasi den ersten
Tag... Du hast bis heute kein Pearl gelernt.
Ich, äh, was? Du hast bis heute
kein Pearl gelernt. Du, das war mein erster
Claim to Fame beim Hacker Jeopardy.
Beim 29C3 gab es in der
Finalrunde eine Kategorie Pearl Operatoren.
Und da war ich bei
Pearl Operatoren für 500, weil ich der einzige
im Saal, der erklären konnte, was der tut.
Da gab es dann
irgendwie einen spontanen
Applaus aus dem Publikum
und dann kam so ein Chant, wo dann das
Publikum gefordert hat, mir den Hauptpreis zu geben.
Also es gibt schon ein Precedent dafür, das war nicht auf dem
Letzt-Näcker-Tipp, das erste Mal.
War das der gleiche Kongress, wo das erste Mal
dieser Perl-Jam vortrag?
Nee, der war später.
Das war glaube ich 30C3.
Das war sogar 31, so 32.
31, genau.
Da war ich auch der erste Fragesteller bei dem.
Da hatte ich auch eine starke Meinung zu.
Naja gut.
Und da hatte ich halt
damals eine Perl-Applikation mit hin. Das war
eines der vorregen Cloud-Produkte vor der Converged Cloud.
Und
Und das ist halt auch so eine Applikation,
die hat halt einmal angefangen,
irgendwie so als, ich klicke mir jetzt eine VM.
Und dann hat sie sich einfach in alle Richtungen ausgedehnt.
Weil quasi immer irgend so Stakeholder angekommen,
sie haben gesagt, es wäre eigentlich noch schön,
wenn es noch so ein Alerting-Dashboard da drin gäbe.
Es wäre eigentlich auch schön,
wenn es noch so eine Ticketplanung drin gäbe.
Ach, es wäre eigentlich auch noch schön,
wenn wir jetzt auch noch ein Sozialabrecher drin machen könnten.
Sowas ähnliches haben wir auch auf Arbeit.
Das wird witzigerweise von ehemaligen SAP-Mitarbeitern entwickelt.
Und das ist halt so ein Knäuel von CGI-Bin-Skripten.
als ich dann gerade ankam, hat man dann gerade
angefangen, die Datei Common PM mal
zu refaktorieren.
Es gab halt ein Perl-Modul, wo alles
drin war, so an Library-Funktionen.
Die haben eine eigene Dateiendung dann?
Naja, quasi PL ist ein Perl-Script
und PM ist ein Perl-Modul.
Common einfacher heißt die.
Nein, weil es PM heißt.
Das heißt Perl-Modul. Das ist halt was, was man
usen kann.
Das eine ist executable, das andere nicht.
Ja, genau. Also bei Python hast du ja immer
dieses komische if name gleich main.
Und wodurch das dann halt quasi beides sein kann.
Und bei Perl ist es schon getrennt.
Und naja, und
was war jetzt die Anekdote, die ich eigentlich
erzähle? Wollen wir zum nächsten
GitHub-Star übergehen? Ja, lass uns das einfach
tun. Kilian, bitte. Ich habe hier
ein wunderbar tolles Projekt von
einem Typen namens Cosmo.
Der hat, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr den
Podcast hört, auch bekannt als der Swift-Community
in Deutschland. Der hat Clippy,
den alten Microsoft Office-Assistenten
auf macOS portiert.
Ich dachte jetzt schon, das ist was von Rust.
Nee, nee, nicht das Kippie. Aber es ist wunderschön.
Er hat sich da auch mit echt tollen Sachen auseinandergesetzt.
Deswegen ist ein Sprite-Kit implementiert,
was Apples
2D-Spiele-Framework eigentlich,
beziehungsweise mit Sprites arbeitet.
Kann man recht viel mitmachen, muss natürlich kein Spiel sein,
aber primär für Spiele benutzt.
Und er hat sich da halt auch wirklich auseinandergesetzt,
die alten Agent-Dateien von Microsoft
halt wirklich zu parsen und die halt wirklich
die offiziellen Sourcen davon
zu interpretieren. Das kann man sich dann als Library
reinziehen in seiner Anwendung? Du kannst halt andere
Agents importieren. Bildung hat er Arbeit eher gerade noch so weit
ich weiß daran. Er rantet halt
die ganze Zeit im Swift.de Slack auch rum über
dieses ekelhafte Agent-Format, was sich Microsoft da ausgedacht
hat, weil es auch wirklich sehr viel zulässt
an Dingen, die die machen können
und die die Frames teilweise halt
sehr unterschiedlich aufgebaut, soweit ich das verstanden
habe. Ich hätte ja gerne so eine Art
Clippy in so einem HAL 9000-Theme,
was halt einfach so eine rote Lampe irgendwie
als freischwebendes Eigen auf deinem Desktop ist.
Da war Clippy sogar wahrscheinlich noch davor, bevor das kam.
I believe I can't let you do that, Dave.
Ja, genau. I'm afraid, er kann das
hier nicht werden.
Aber es ist wunderbar. Es ist großartig toll.
Hat jetzt auch gerade in den letzten Tagen sehr viel
Popularität dazugewonnen.
Ich finde es fantastisch. Tolles Projekt.
Kennt ihr eigentlich die Hintergrundgeschichte hinter diesem
Daisy, Daisy, was
Hall 9000 da singt?
Nee. Und zwar,
das habe ich witzigerweise in meinem Nebenfach
Studium gelernt. Es gibt,
ich habe im Nebenfach Musikwissenschaft studiert
und da habe ich einen Vortrag über,
oder gab es einen Vortrag über
Computermusik. Es gab Leute,
die sich in den 60er Jahren bei den Bell Labs
mit Musik und
Stimmsynthese auseinandergesetzt haben.
Und da gab es als eine Demo
wurde dieses Lied
1961 oder 62
komplett synthetisiert auf einem Computer
gespielt. Klazer Scheiß.
Der Kubrick hat sich das halt
in der Vorbereitung für seinen Film mal zeigen lassen.
Und war dann so fasziniert.
In dem Film hat das tatsächlich ein Mensch
eingesungen. Die haben es bloß so ein bisschen verzerrt.
Aber das Original, das suche ich gerade mal raus, das war wirklich komplett synthetisiert.
Genau, First Computer to Sing, das klingt dann so.
Daisy, Daisy, take me your answer to
I'm mad crazy all for the love of you
It would be a stylish wearing
I can't afford a carry
Gut, wir haben es gehört.
Copyright Strike 1.
Jetzt kriegen wir wirklich mal die Abwahl.
Wir müssen mindestens als allererstes von STD Out auf die Fresse kriegen.
Ja, stimmt. Das haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Aber da du sagst, du hast im Nebenfach Musikwissenschaften studiert,
da kann ich noch eine Anekdote einschwenken,
um unsere Sendeszeit noch weiter auszufüllen.
Bitte.
Wir sind bei Föhnbindenden zwei Minuten zwölf.
Ja, das ist ja kurz.
Das ist schon der dritte Tag, an dem die Leute diese Folge hören.
Da habe ich noch nicht mal richtig die Geschwindigkeit eingestellt,
sondern es ist schon wieder vorbei.
Zumindest ein Hin- und Rückflug nach Schweden.
Genau, und zwar habe ich damals am Musikgymnasium,
nee, nicht studiert, sondern geschult.
Du bist zur Schule gegangen?
Ich bin auf ein Musikgymnasium gegangen.
Ja.
Und ich hatte damals Klavier gespielt
und dann einigermaßen singen konnte ich dann wie auch noch
mit dem entsprechenden Stimmbildungsunterricht,
den man dann auch bekommen hat.
Das war aber eigentlich aus bürokratischen Dingen
total wichtig, dass ich dieses Musikgymnasium besucht habe.
Denn wir haben nicht in Spirin gewohnt,
sondern in einem Vorort,
der quasi so drei Meter hinter der Stadtgrenze ist.
Das heißt, ich habe im Landkreis gewohnt
und hätte im Landkreis zur Schule gehen müssen.
Das wäre total die falsche Richtung gewesen.
Da hätte ich quasi 25 Kilometer weg von Spirin fahren müssen,
um ins Gymnasium zu gehen.
Und das war halt
an Betrachtest, dass meine Familie komplett in Schwerin
gearbeitet hat und auch zum Beispiel meine Großmutter,
wo ich dann irgendwie nach mir das verbracht habe.
Bist du halt auf die musikalische Schule gegangen?
Deswegen wurde dann halt als Hack dann wie gefunden, also erst war ich
dann auf so einer Privatschule vor einem Jahr,
so einem Privatgymnasium, was aber
auch nicht so geil war und dann wurde die Lösung gefunden,
ich gehe einfach auf ein Musikgymnasium, denn das gibt es
in Schwerin nur und nicht im Landkreis.
Musst du dann noch schnell Klavierspielen lernen?
Nee, das hatte ich schon länger gemacht, aber
ja, ich musste dann halt irgendwie einmal im Jahr,
nee, zweimal im Jahr musste ich vorspielen und vorsingen
und musste halt quasi
in so einer Musikklasse.
Und ich habe dann aber
das noch gerade so
abwenden können, in den Musikleistungskurs zu gehen,
weil das wäre dann doch ein bisschen
intens geworden. Da gab es dann
auch so einen Musikoberstufenleiter,
der sehr ambitioniert
war und dann mit seinem
Jugendchor an Dorn dann durch die Weltgeschichte
geguckt ist und so. Das wäre dann
ziemlich anstrengend geworden, aber dann gab es dann auch
wieder so ein Loophole im Gesetz, dass nämlich, wenn du
einmal Abitur anfängst, in einer bestimmten Schule
darf dann der Landkreis nicht
dich dazu zwingen, während dieser Abiturjahrgänge
die Schule nochmal zu wechseln. Und deswegen
konnte ich dann quasi in dem Moment, wo dann
die Leistungskurse losgehen, konnte ich da
Mathe und Physik belegen und anstatt Musik.
Nein, nein.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich ein paar Jahre
den Bildungsunterricht erhalten. Ich kann tatsächlich irgendwie
einigermaßen singen. Aber ich werde das
jetzt hier nicht machen, weil das ist schon eine fortgeschrittene Stunde.
Wir wollen ja deine Nachbarn nicht
verwirren.
Ich habe tatsächlich noch, ich kann das noch mal kurz halten,
Ich habe noch ein neues Tool gefunden,
was tatsächlich jetzt auch ein anderes Team bei uns
im Repo einsetzt.
Und zwar heißt das Volta.
Der Name ist ein bisschen seltsam,
aber findet man auf Volta.sh
und es ist ein in Rust geschriebener
Ersatz für NVS oder NVM.
Quasi ein Version-Management
für JavaScript-Pakete und für JavaScript-Binaries.
Ist auch geil, dass die ganze
JavaScript-Ecosystem
jetzt auf in Rust geschriebenes Tooling umsteigt.
Das ist tatsächlich entwickelt von
dem Chris Kreicho.
mit unter anderem. Ich bin auch
darüber gekommen, dass der in irgendeinem anderen Podcast,
den ich auch sehr empfehlen kann, nämlich
Co-Recursive
zu Gast war.
Ausgezeichneter Podcast. Und da hat er
über dieses Tool geredet, dass er
in Rust für
JavaScript, was er ja sonst eigentlich volltags
macht, oh, volltags,
also ganztägig,
genau, und
als ich mir das das erste Mal angeguckt habe, war es noch nicht ganz
Primetime. Jetzt ist es immer noch nicht ganz Primetime,
aber man kann es schon einigermaßen benutzen.
Und das Schöne ist halt, dass es so ein bisschen den Ansatz von Rustup verwendet, das heißt, alle meine Binerys, die ich installiert habe, sind eigentlich Simlinks auf eine Shim-Binary, die ist mit installiert, die dann vor Ort entscheidet, je nachdem in welchem Environment sie ist, welche Version von der Binary sie tatsächlich ausführen soll.
Das heißt, du kannst in deinem Ordner sein, wo du eine bestimmte Package-JSON hast und in der Package-JSON entweder hat es sich implizit für diese Location gemerkt, dass es dort eine bestimmte Node-Version zu verwenden hat oder es ist in der Package-JSON gepinnt.
da hast du einen Unterblock Volta, da steht drin
Node D&D Version oder Yarm D&D Version
oder TypeScript oder diverse
andere Binarys, die du normalerweise
mit NPM global irgendwo installieren
würdest oder mit NVS irgendwo installieren
würdest und die werden dann mit den
deren Versionen
werden dann je nach den Bedingungen geswitcht.
Das funktioniert dann ziemlich gut. Das heißt,
was mir aufgefallen ist,
als ich das Projekt von diesem anderen Team,
an dem ich nicht ständig mitarbeite,
zum ersten Mal ausgecheckt habe und da was ausführen
wollte, hat es im ersten Moment erstmal das aktuelle
Node zu diesem Ding runtergeladen und dann das
korrekte Node dafür ausgeführt.
Es ist nicht ständig notwendig, gerade
bei Node, weil es sich nicht mehr so viel verändert, aber
wenn es für sowas wie
TypeScript oder sowas vorwendet, ist es eigentlich ganz nice.
Weil manchmal kriegst du irgendwie auf die Finger
von irgendeinem Tooling, dass du dir sagst, naja, wir haben jetzt
gerade wenn drinsteht, in der Package-Dation
kann drinstehen, diese und jene Engine
und wenn du dann mit der falschen Node-Version
kommst, dann führt das Ding nicht aus, dann denkst du jetzt
jetzt muss ich irgendwie diese Befehle für
NVS oder NVM wieder, wie ich das richtig
und das macht Volta automatisch.
Klingt praktisch.
Ich hätte das gerne noch für andere Sachen wie
Ruby oder Python.
Das ist noch nicht vorgesehen.
Ja, ich habe noch
einen Star gefunden in meiner Liste
von GitHub Stars, die sie über die
Jahrhaken gesammelt haben, wobei ich da relativ sparsam bin
mit Star, weil sonst finde ich ja nichts mehr wieder.
Und zwar
MPV Empress, also
eine Kette von Akronymen, die da
zu einem Namen zusammengesetzt werden.
Das ist ein Plugin für MPV, was so ein M-Player-Fork ist,
der so mein Go-To-Media-Player für alles ist,
der zum Beispiel auch deswegen relativ geil ist,
weil er YouTube-DL einfach integriert hat.
Also ich kann da irgendwie so irgendeine Webseiten-UR reinwerfen
und der zieht halt das Video raus und spielt mir das einfach ab.
MPV ist echt schick.
Als richtiger Media-Player, der ein nicht furchtbares Interface hat,
wo man tatsächlich mit einem Tastendruck die Geschwindigkeit ändern kann,
anstatt sich da mit so einem Menü durchzugraben,
oder es geht gleich gar nicht.
Oder man kann dann auch auf so einer beschissenen Webseite
dann plötzlich auch Single-Frame-Stepping machen und sowas.
Und was da halt noch so ein bisschen gefehlt hat für mich,
was halt dieses Plugin macht, ist eine Empress-Schnittstelle.
Das ist die Media Player Remote Interface Specification.
Das ist unter Linux mit diesem D-Bus gemacht,
was halt so ein IPC-Tooling ist für Linux.
Und Empress ist halt ein Standardweg,
wie sich so ein Media Player announcen kann.
So von wegen, ich bin ein Media Player.
Und hier sind meine Controls.
Und das ist das Video, was gerade läuft und so weiter.
sodass du dann, wenn du zum Beispiel deinen Desktop sperrst,
dann siehst du halt, wenn du zum Beispiel KDE verwendest,
dann kriegst du auf dem Sperrbildschirm halt die Mediakontrolls angezeigt
und kannst halt auch ohne zu entsperren die Musik pausieren oder weiterlaufen lassen.
Habe ich noch nicht festgestellt, das macht selbst Chrome ganz cool
und wenn du KDE Connect hast, dann kannst du einfach dein KDE Connect rausholen
und wenn du dann gerade Netflix guckst, dann kannst du mit deinem Handy plötzlich
zumindest Pause und Play wieder drücken.
Musst dich aufstehen.
Genau, also bei KDE Connect, das Kontrollieren hat das schon einigermaßen ganz gut funktioniert,
weil das hat auch so eine Ferneingabefunktion bei KDE Connect,
dass man halt hier so einen Screen aufmachen kann in der App
und dann kann man quasi den Touchscreen als Maus verwenden
und man kann dann auch die Tastatur aufmachen von der App
und dann kann man da halt tippen und das kommt da auf dem Desktop an
und dann kann man sich dann auch aus dem F-Droid-Store dann das Hackers-Keyboard installieren,
dann kriegt man auch irgendwie F11 und sowas.
Das war eine tolle 3-Guard-Keyboard, die habe ich auch geliebt, als ich mein Android genutzt habe.
Und was ich ja persönlich das allermagischste Feature finde,
ist, das hat mich das erste Mal total,
da war ich total verwirrt davon,
da hatte ich gerade einen Film geguckt,
da waren auch Leute zu Besuch,
und plötzlich hält der Film an.
Ich so, warum hält der Film an?
In dem Moment klingelt mein Telefon.
Und dann habe ich so gedacht,
ach so ja, KDE Connect hat so ein Feature,
dass es die Wiedergabe anhält,
wenn du einen Anruf entgegennimmst.
Dann habe ich halt diesen Anruf entgegengenommen,
aufgelegt, der Film läuft weiter.
Und da dachte ich so,
eigentlich hätte man... Jetzt ist die Zukunft.
Eigentlich müsste man KDE Connect
ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit schenken,
weil viele von diesen Features, die da drin waren,
die sind dann irgendwie ein Dreivierteljahr später
auf irgendeiner Apple Keynote dann als das
geile neue iPhone-Feature vorgestellt worden.
Vielleicht ist da auch irgendwas geleakt worden
und die haben es schnell in KDE eingebaut, aber es war
zumindest ein KDE Connect, waren viele
von diesen Features drin, bevor sie auf dem iPhone
vorführen waren. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich da abschauen, aber
es ergibt ja auch nur Sinn, wenn du das Ecosystem hast,
dass du auch die Shared Clip-Boat zum Beispiel... Genau.
Das ist das, was mich dann an Linux wieder ankotzt.
Es gab dann irgendjemanden, der sowas für Gnomen
bauen wollte und der hatte irgendwie
rumgeschrieben, ja, ich baue jetzt irgendwie was, ich fand das eigentlich ganz
cool. Die Idee, die ich neulich hatte, dass ich
irgendwie mit meinem Telefon das mit meinem Desktop
verbinden könnte oder kann man mit Clipper
sharen und so Sachen machen und dann
schreibt einer von der Seite rein, hast du dir mal KDE
Connect angeguckt? Wie, KDE hat
sowas schon? Ja. Und dann haben sie es aber
irgendwie nicht hingekriegt, dass die Gnomenleute und
KDE-Leute sich irgendwie auf was einigen, dass das
natürlich nicht... Natürlich nicht Standard.
Das können wir nochmal wieder zuschreiben.
Es gibt einen App-Indicator für KDE-Connect,
sodass das auch in anderen Desktops verwendet werden kann.
Allerdings ist dann, gerade bei Gnome ist dann noch so die Frage,
ob das dann wie komplett integriert ist und sowas,
weil es integriert sich ja auch teilweise noch mit dem Desktop und so.
Aber zumindest so, dass Centu scheint hier zu funktionieren
und irgendwie Batterieanzeige und das Notifications vom Telefon
halt auch auf dem Desktop kriegst.
Es gibt ja diese Cross-Desktop-Kollaboration
zwischen den einzelnen Desktop-Herstellen.
deswegen funktioniert das sowas wie Desktop-Notifications
auch zwischen unterschiedlichen...
Es funktioniert so leidlich.
Also ich habe es ja auch, als ich damals bei KDE mit drinsteckte,
habe ich das so ein bisschen mitbekommen.
Und also es gab halt mal so diesen initialen Push,
da sind halt solche Spezifikationen,
so wie diese gemeinsamen Icon-Set-Spezifikationen rausgekommen
und diese Desktop-Files, solche Sachen.
Aber es sind halt so relativ viele Specs,
die halt einfach nur so sind,
irgendwie Gnomendruck streicht halt in ihren Specs mal Gnomendurch,
und streit xdg hin und legt das dann halt so hin
und ohne dass irgendjemand das abgesprochen wurde.
Ja, also es bleibt weit hinter seinen Möglichkeiten zurück.
Ich habe für mein erstes größeres Rust-Projekt,
das ist diese Library, die mit Debus redet,
und Desktop-Notifications ermöglicht.
Die hat irgendwie bislang 34.000 Downloads.
Das hat mich ein bisschen geflasht.
Ich habe mir Mühe gegeben, diese gesamte Spec,
es gab erstens zwei oder drei Stellen,
wo diese Spec hingeschrieben war.
Ich habe mir Mühe gegeben, sie einigermaßen hinzuschreiben.
sie wird allerdings von keinem Desktop
vollständig implementiert, es gibt so ein paar Features da drin
wie Sounds oder sowas, die glaube ich keiner implementiert
weil sie sich so hinterher wahrscheinlich auch gedacht haben
wer zum Geher möchte, dass Anwendungen irgendwie Sounds
abspielen können mit Discord Notifications
neulich hat mich tatsächlich mal jemand angeschrieben auf dieses
Sound Feature, ich sag mal
funktioniert dieses Sound Dings überhaupt
bei Desktop Notifications auf KDI
und ich so, ich wüsste von keinem Desktop
der das überhaupt implementiert, aber es steht da leider
drin und deswegen habe ich es implementiert
ja und da gibt es viele Sachen
wo sie leider hinter ihren Möglichkeiten
zurückbleiben.
Es gibt auch ein wunderschönes Zeiterfassungstool
für Gnome, was ich gefunden habe,
als ich meine Zeit lang an den Anfangszeiten
von KDE 4 auf Gnome
zurück umgestiegen bin, was das heißt
Hamster. Damit habe ich meine
Studenten, meine SHK,
aber Zeitabrechnung gemacht. Da hast du einfach
gesagt, du konntest irgendwie so eine Liste
von Items erzeugen und dann kannst du
sagen, ich mache jetzt das und dann klickst du auf das andere,
ich mache jetzt das. Und das hat dir so ein Gantt-Chart
erzeugt und im Zweifelsfall eine CSV-Datei
und das war eigentlich ziemlich nice.
funktioniert natürlich nicht auf GNOME, weil
das kein normales Desktop-Icon ist, sondern
es funktioniert auch schon auf GNOME
3 nicht mehr.
Wollen wir da langsam
mal zum Ende kommen?
Aus deinem Mund.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt schon eine
beträchtliche Folgelänge erreicht
mit fast dreieinhalb,
zweieinhalb Stunden.
Mit fast zweieinhalb Stunden.
Ihr bräuchtet jetzt noch, wie beim Aufwachen-Podcast,
noch eine Stunde höhere Kommentare hinterher.
Oh Gott, um Gottes Willen.
Also wir nennen jetzt noch alle 100 Hörer,
die normalerweise unsere Folge runterladen,
namentlich.
Also wir haben den.
Nee.
Ich hatte ja
in der letzten
Folge vom letzten November vom Penta-Radio,
da hatte ich so einen Running-Gag, dass ich
gesagt habe, unsere drei Hörer.
Weißt du, wie viele Leute das Penta-Radio?
Aber wir haben auf jeden Fall danach festgestellt,
da gab es jede Menge Rückmeldungen, wir haben mehr als drei Hörer.
Weißt du, wie viele
Hörer das Penta-Radio hat oder das
Penta-Cast hat? Das ist gar nicht so einfach
festzustellen. Also ich meine,
wir haben ja keine Metriken oder sowas.
Nee, sowas will man ja auch nicht mehr Podcast, aber du siehst zumindest
Download-Zahlen von dem Feed in den
Logs allein schon, wie viele Leute das sind.
Also ich zumindest auf meinem privaten Server habe ich gar keine
Logs. Tja, finde ich gut.
Das steht auch in der Datenschutz-Erklärung.
Die Datenschutz-Erklärung ist eine Zeile, nämlich
kein System unter meiner Kontrolle erhebt,
speichert irgendwelche persönlichen Daten.
Super. Ich habe nur
so einen Error-Log von wegen irgendwie
Nginx-Config geht nicht oder so.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Versprechen, was wir mit nicht machen können,
aber wir sind ja bei
Simplecast, weil
wir uns wirklich keine Arbeit machen wollten.
Wir sehen, dass du sehr viel Liebe
und Zeit in deine Webseite gesteckt hast, aber
das haben wir irgendwie nicht geschafft.
Ich wollte neulich irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen
von euch mal eine Folge runterladen
und habe
so lange gegen kämpfen müssen,
bis ich irgendwann mal dieses File
wirklich bekommen habe. Ich glaube, ich habe am Ende den
RSS-Feed gelesen, weil den können sie mir
nicht vorenthalten, den müssen sie irgendwo geben
und da ist dann halt dieser Link drin, den ich
tatsächlich nehmen kann, aber irgendwie aus dieser Webseite
heraus so ein Download-Club fehlt.
Nee, da ist ein Download-Club-Filter, das stimmt.
Wenn du einen anderen guten Podcast-as-a-Service-Anbieter
empfehlen. Wir haben uns so viele Gedanken
gemacht am Anfang, wir wollten ja sogar die Podcasts über IPFS
hosten und wir haben uns so
zu viele Gedanken gemacht.
Astro hat so ein Projekt
Bitlove
hier
wo du deinen RSS-Feed reinschmeißt
und der siehle den nach
Bitlochend rein. Machen wir auch.
Aber er hostet es nicht für dich.
Ja eben, aber du kriegst auch keine, also die klassischen
HTTP-Tarbonos laufen noch nicht darüber, oder? Das ist nur
zusätzliche Verteilung davon, was toll ist, super.
Aber das hilft uns nicht.
Also bei Potlove heißt es, oder?
Nee, Potlove heißt es.
Bitlove heißt es, Bitlove, genau.
Wenn es das noch gibt,
hier wird das direkt vervollständigt
bei mir, bitlove.org
slash akronomisierbar, gibt es unseren Feed.
Wird mir vorgeschlagen, dass ich das mit
Bibdesk aufmachen soll.
Ach, der hat aber den falschen Torrentlink,
weil der hat die letzte Not-Folge runtergeladen.
Ups, dann müssen wir uns mal bei Bitlove
mal aktuellen.
Die nicht 14. Goodbye Soundcloud.
Wo die letzte Folge ist, wenn du das hörst,
dann hast du ja den falschen Feed.
Das haben wir extra nur auf dem Soundcloud-Feed veröffentlicht.
Ja.
Also wir haben, was ich eigentlich gerade sagen wollte,
ist, also wir haben, wir können zumindest
über Simplecast einsehen, dass wir pro Folge
so zwischen 100 bis
150 Downloads.
Was ich recht interessant finde, ist, der schaut sich auch
die User-Agents an. Also Downloads von der Folge. Genau.
Das hängt ein bisschen ab. Manche treffen
auch über die 200 noch hinweg. Was ich aber
recht spannend finde, sind noch die User-Agents
der Downloader,
weil die meisten Podcast-Clients das halt
mitschicken. Das ist halt wirklich, was
die Client-Landschaft so ist und das ist halt
was ich immer mit überraschend finde, das ist so
60-70% halt wirklich
iOS ist, mit auf
diversen Clients und der Rest halt verteilt.
Das hat aber auch mit eurer Bubble zu tun.
Nee, das ist wirklich recht typisch.
Zum Teil ist es die Bubble, klar.
Also gerade der Tech-Podcast-Ansatz.
Zum anderen ist aber auch
wirklich sehr, sehr typisch.
Ich meine zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt halt im Hackspace
irgendwie rumschauen würde, hätte ich glaube ich relativ wenig
Leute, die iPhones haben.
Würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren, weil ich glaube,
die Zahl ist größer, als du denkst.
Aber ich vermute mal, dass
Penta Radio mehr Hörer hat. Also einmal gibt es das natürlich
länger und zweitens mal ist das ja auch
im CCC-Umfeld halt eine bekannte Sache.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe halt echt gestaunt,
die letzten paar Male, also auch als ich diesen
Pentacast veröffentlicht hatte, dachte ich auch so, da kommt jetzt erstmal
überhaupt kein Feedback rüber, weil das ja auch so seit
nach zwei Jahren das erste Mal ist.
Und so quasi eine Stunde später
oder so war das dann beim Twitter-Feed
vom CCC e.V., also
bei Twitter slash Chaos-Updates,
wurde das dann geplagt, wo ich so dachte,
geil, cool, ja, doch.
Und hat dann auch irgendwie nochmal so ein Dutzend
Read-Feeds und so bekommen. Also das scheinen ja
deswegen schon mitzubekommen und
deswegen würde ich mal spekulieren, dass es mehr als
100 Hörer hat am Ende.
Auch wenn wir natürlich jetzt diesen
Running Gag da hatten.
Alle drei Hörer.
Und ja, also von daher
wir müssen auch mal eine Folge machen, wo ihr mal zu Gast seid.
Da können wir uns noch ein Thema ausdenken.
Sehr gerne. Pettercast oder die gesamte...
Dann werdet ihr auch ein paar neue Hörer bekommen.
Die gesamte Petter-Marke ist ja
schon ein relativ bekannter Hausnummer
gerade zu investieren,
dieser lokalen Hacker-Bubble.
na gut, ja, freuen wir uns
sehr drauf, also demnächst sind wir wahrscheinlich mal beim
PentaCast zu Gast
ich warte dir ja schon mal beim PentaCast zu Gast
ich habe dafür sogar extra meinen Urlaub kurzzeitig
unterbrochen, um nach Dresden zurückzufahren
mit Astro eine Runde über Russ zu reden
und dann wieder zurück aufs Land zu düsen
und mich dann wieder
selbstgemachtem Käse zu widmen
das war
akronomisierbar, Folge
diesmal zu Gast
eine Rundezahl?
Ja, wir haben die 5-Bit voll.
Krass.
Beeindruckend.
Diesmal zu Gast mit Stefan Majewski,
auch bekannt unter dem,
das musst du aussprechen.
Xyrel.
Pseudonym.
Schaut euch seine Webseite an.
Er findet ihn auf
xyri.lian.de
Er holt seine
Podcaster-Stimme raus.
Hast du Sachen auf GitHub?
Ich habe dich da gerade mal gesucht.
Ja, github.com.
Majewski. M-A-J-E-W-S-K-Y.
Ja, das ist einfach nur
mein Nachname. Das war, bevor es den Nickname gab
und das ändere ich auch jetzt nicht mehr.
Das ist richtig. Ich wollte mal deine Stars sagen.
Das bricht nur so viele Dinge.
Genau, das war Folge 32.
Schön, dass ihr so lange
durchgehalten habt. Ihr könnt uns
ja mal auf Twitter schreiben, wie viele Tage
ihr an dieser Folge gehört habt mit Unterbrechungen
zwischendurch. Das fände ich bloß mal so als Erhebung
spannend. Und
wenn ihr jetzt noch weiter Lust auf Podcast hören
kommt, in eurem Podcatcher kommt bestimmt
gleich die nächste komplett
unabhängig von hier produzierte
Sendung in drei,
zwei, eins.
Piep.
Sehr schön.
Ich habe noch zu dem...